My back is sweating from drinking hot tea. My front is sweating. I have sweats on. I'm sweating. Showing your microphone is on. Oh, sorry. Showing your microphone is on. Sorry, sorry, sorry.
喝了热茶，我的后背在出汗。我的前胸在出汗。我一直在出汗。我在出汗。显示你的麦克风开着。哦，抱歉。显示你的麦克风开着。抱歉，抱歉，抱歉。
Why do you think they call it sweats? You think they call it sweats because you're supposed to sweat in those clothes? Yeah, probably. But what do they not invent shorts? No, but do they look up in the center of a genius sandwich? Fuck it out. But why would you, if you're gonna make sweats, why did they not have shorts back then?
你觉得为什么它们叫运动裤（sweats）？你觉得叫运动裤是因为你应该穿着那种衣服出汗吗？对，可能吧。但是为什么它们没有发明短裤呢？不对，但它们是不是像天才三明治的中心一样被想出来的？真他妈绝了。但是为什么，如果你要做运动裤，为什么那个时候没有短裤呢？
No, I know. They need like a pull-away sweats. So they could just... They've got sweats from sweats to shorts, like in a second. Yeah, you ever a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, Smart. Lies. Smart. Blast. Hey, good morning. Is this better for everybody? 9.30 in the morning? Hi, is it good morning better now? How about it?
不，我知道。它们需要那种一撕就能脱的运动裤。这样它们就能直接……它们一秒钟就能把运动裤变成短裤。对，你有没有……聪明。谎言。聪明。太棒了。嘿，早安。这样对大家更好吗？早上9点半。嗨，现在早安感觉好点了吗？怎么样？
We're going to have a little less complain. Who's complaining? No, we had a few late night. Well, one of them you called a late night. It was a 4 p.m. Yeah, I was already in my pajamas. Oh, well, that had a few late night. Well, one of them you called a late night, it was a four p.m. I was already in my pajamas. Oh, well, that's pretty late. I know.
我们要少抱怨一点。谁在抱怨？不，我们有几次熬夜。好吧，其中有一次你说是熬夜。那是下午4点。对，我当时已经穿上睡衣了。哦，好吧，那确实有几次熬夜。好吧，其中有一次你说是熬夜，那是下午4点。我当时已经穿上睡衣了。哦，好吧，那挺晚的。我知道。
That's a late night, unless you're in Hawaii. I know. You know, and it's lunch. Right now, it's lunch in New York City. It's lunch in New York City. But it's breakfast here in LA. Yeah. It is. Look, I got my tea. Morning, you guys.
那是熬夜，除非你在夏威夷。我知道。你知道的，现在是午餐时间。现在，在纽约市正是吃午餐的时间。在纽约市是吃午餐的时间。但这里是洛杉矶的早餐时间。对。确实是。看，我带着我的茶。大家早。
What did you guys have for breakfast this morning? Nothing yet. Really? I actually had a piece of toast with some natural peanut butter and a couple slices of banana on top. Sounds fun. What was it feeling great this morning? Oh, really? What happened? I don't know. What's, what's, what's, is it tummy? Yeah, a little tummy and, um, What's, what's, what's, what's, is it tummy? Is it bad? Little tummy and, and baby woke up in the night, when he's not a baby anymore, but a little throw up in the middle of the night.
你们今天早上吃什么了？什么都没吃。真的吗？我其实吃了一片涂了天然花生酱的吐司，上面还放了几片香蕉。听起来不错。今天早上感觉很棒吗？哦，真的吗？怎么了？我不知道。怎么了，怎么了，是肚子吗？对，有点肚子疼，而且……怎么了，怎么了，是肚子吗？很严重吗？有点肚子疼，而且宝宝半夜醒了，虽然他已经不是婴儿了，但半夜还是吐了一点。
Oh my God, Ricky threw it last night. Really? Yeah. Maybe Danny got into your trash, right? Ricky. Um, the, I don't, I don't eat till noon. Is that right? Yeah.
天哪，里奇昨晚吐了。真的吗？对。也许丹尼翻了你的垃圾桶吧，对吧？里奇。嗯，我，我直到中午才吃东西。是吗？对。
It's too much. It's fucking watch out. I don't, I don't eat till noon. Is that right? Yeah. It's been a minute. Then it's fucking watch out. Everything real trouble. Do you really do it? You do that like that fasting thing? Is that what time the timer on the locks goes off on the cabinet? The cabinet. That's what Scottie said all the timers for.
这太过了。他妈的小心点。我直到中午才吃东西。是吗？对。有一会儿了。然后就他妈的要小心了。所有东西都要出大问题。你真的这么做吗？你做那种禁食吗？是不是橱柜锁上的定时器响起的时间？橱柜。斯科蒂就是这么说的，定时器是干这个的。
Yeah, you can hear the tick tick. Are you doing a, let's not eat for... Well, I'll just think. Yeah, sure. I'm just never, ever, have never been hungry ever in my whole life in the morning. I just, the first time I eat it. But you are right about to watch out.
对，你能听到滴答声。你是在做那个，我们不吃……好吧，我只想一下。好吧，当然。我这辈子早上从来、从来、从来没有饿过。我只是，我吃东西的时候……但你马上就要小心了。
I'll eat everything. And then you'll go late. Will you eat late? No, and then I'll have a really little dinner. That's it. Well, let's check the tape on that. Will, can we run the tape on that? Yeah, I mean, I just can say,
我会吃掉所有东西。然后你会吃得很晚。你会吃得很晚吗？不，然后我会吃一顿非常少量的晚餐。就这样。好吧，我们去查查那天的录像吧。威利，我们能查查当天的录像吗？对，我的意思是，我只想说，
that's a little heavy on the cheese, like, whatever. No, I eat just a little, but I do, I eat little portions so I can eat big desserts. Right, yeah. You saved the room for the dessert. Yeah, for sure. Yeah.
那个芝士有点多，随便吧。不，我只吃一点点，但我确实吃得很小份，这样我就可以吃大份的甜点。对，没错。你给甜点留了肚子。对，肯定的。对。
I made a mistake. The yesterday, Will FaceTime me, I was in the middle of therapy, and I was like, yeah, I'll pick it up. And she's like, oh, excuse me. And I was like, yeah. And therapist is like, oh, what are you doing? And he says, and the first thing he says is, hey, man, I go, hey, he goes, I go, I'm in therapy.
我犯了个错误。昨天，威利通过FaceTime打给我，我正在做心理治疗，我想，好吧，我接一下。然后她说，哦，打扰一下。我说，好吧。然后治疗师说，哦，你在干什么？他说，他说的第一句话是，嘿，老兄，我说，嘿，他说，我说，我在做治疗。
And I showed a picture, I turned the camera around to show him my therapist is like, hello. And he goes, oh, my therapist just died. I was like, really? And he said, he collapse from the weight of my secrets. That was pretty funny. Do you often take calls during therapy? No, but my phone just happened to be like the flap open.
我还展示了一张照片，我把摄像头转过去给他看我的治疗师，治疗师说了声“你好”。然后他说，哦，我的治疗师刚刚死了。我说，真的吗？他说，他被我那些秘密的重量压垮了。这挺搞笑的。你经常在做治疗期间接电话吗？不，但我的手机刚好是那种翻盖开着的。
You know, you call it my purse. Oh, right. And yeah, and I saw that it was a phone book. My phone book. Huh. Huh. Gosh, we get into it. This is fun.
你知道的，你叫我的钱包。哦，对。然后，是的，我看到那是一个电话本。我的电话本。哈。哈。天哪，我们开始聊这个了。这挺有意思的。
I mean, is it too early to do a podcast? No, it's not too early. We're still in bed. No, it's not too early. I'm just a little quiet today. Like I said, I'm feeling very, maybe, Spellcus, what's the, what's the Yiddish term? Because you didn't sleep.
我是说，现在做播客会不会太早？不，不早。我们还在床上。不，不早。我今天只是有点安静。就像我说的，我觉得非常，也许，Spellcus，那个意第绪语词是什么？因为你没睡。
You're like, you're a little LGD, low grade depression. Yeah, maybe, maybe it is. I don't know. I wouldn't call it that, but maybe it is, but also just very sort of, very kind of, kind of, pensive. Yeah, that's a bad thing. Yeah, that's right. Well, that's all right,
你就像，你有点LGD，轻度抑郁。对，也许，也许是吧。我不知道。我不会那样叫它，但也许是的，不过也只是非常那种，非常温和的、沉思的。对，这不是件坏事。对，没错。好吧，没关系，
because you know, you know, it's gonna put a nice wash of warms and positivity over your day. Our guest is like, great, I gotta lift the hosts up. Yeah. Here she comes. Our guest is an actor.
因为你知道，你知道的，这会在你的一天中注入一层美好的温暖和积极的情绪。我们的嘉宾就像是，太棒了，我得把主持人们的情绪调动起来。对。她来了。我们的嘉宾是一位演员。
So filled with taste talent and accomplishment, I feel classy just thinking about her, you guys. She's got the awards and nominations, sure, a long list of impressive films and a stack of big shot co-stars and directors, but most impressive will is a particular kind of light that she sends out from the character she plays. It's always something authentic.
她充满了品位、才华和成就，一想到她，我就觉得自己很有品位，伙计们。她拿过奖项和提名，当然，还有一长串令人印象深刻的电影作品以及一大堆大牌合作演员和导演，但最让人印象深刻的是，威利，是她从自己扮演的角色中散发出的一种特有的光芒。那总是某种真实的东西。
It's fully human, often complex, but somehow fully relatable. We never catch our acting will. It always just feels like we're spying on a character caught in the middle of something, you know, Sean? How does she do it? What do we personalize as well? Is she enjoying it? Hope we're gonna find out.
那是完全人性化的，通常很复杂，但不知为何又完全能引起共鸣。威利，我们从来没有抓到过她在演戏。感觉就像我们在偷窥一个被困在某种情境中的角色，你知道吗，肖恩？她是怎么做到的？威利，我们还在个性化什么？她享受其中吗？希望我们能一探究竟。
What else does she do? Hobbies? Really? Is it like being married to a rock star? Does she prefer coffee? Tea? Cake? Pie? Beyonce or Tate-Tate?
她还做什么？爱好？真的吗？就像嫁给了一个摇滚巨星吗？她更喜欢咖啡？茶？蛋糕？派？碧昂丝还是泰勒·斯威夫特？
Guys, let's figure it all out. Please welcome Carrie Mulligan. Oh, Carrie. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. Oh, wow. Oh, well, don't you feel warm and washed? I do.
伙计们，让我们把这一切都弄清楚吧。请欢迎凯瑞·穆里根。哦，凯瑞。天哪。天哪。哦，哇。哦，好吧，你难道不觉得温暖和被洗涤了吗？我确实觉得。
I am a particular fan of Carrie's. Well, a huge fan. It's true. Well, Carrie, it's true. I told you, I was, I've had the pleasure. I've had the, the, the, the, the, yeah, sure. I've seen, I've seen Carrie's latest performance in my show, and I, and it has rocked me since the day I've seen it.
我是凯瑞的超级粉丝。嗯，巨大的粉丝。真的。好吧，凯瑞，这是真的。我告诉过你了，我是，我有幸。我有，有，有，有，有，是的，当然。我看过，我在我的节目里看过凯瑞最新的表演，而且，自打我看到它的那一天起，它就震撼了我。
Carrie, I've been telling everybody, I don't want to embarrass you. You're so sweet. It's true. I was so nervous when we, when I, when you were at, hi everyone, by the way, hi. Hi, Carrie. This is a nice to meet you. So nice to meet you.
凯瑞，我一直在告诉所有人，我不想让你尴尬。你太甜了。真的。当我们，当我，当你在的时候，我好紧张，嗨，顺便大家好，嗨。嗨，凯瑞。很高兴认识你。很高兴认识你。
I was so nervous that you were at Radley's house and we had that screening. And all I wanted to say the whole night was, Marcus and I fall asleep to rest in development, not an unfolding sleeper, but like that's all. You said it. That's very sad. We literally, I can quote the show.
我太紧张了，你当时在拉德利的家里，我们有那场放映。我整晚只想说的是，马库斯和我是一边看《发展受阻》一边入睡的，不是那种可以展开的沙发床，而是……你就这么说了。这太让人难过了。我们真的，我可以引用那部剧的台词。
And I was too nervous to say anything and after it's Marcus, I was like, why are you so cool? You should have just said it. And I was like, I got, but I was so excited and so nervous for you to see it. And it meant the world that you liked it. So great. Oh, great.
我当时太紧张了，什么也没说，事后我对马库斯说，你为什么这么酷？你刚才就应该说出来的。然后我说，我，但我太兴奋了，也为你看到它而感到紧张。你能喜欢它，对我来说意义重大。太棒了。哦，太棒了。
Love it. Love it. I can't wait to see it. But, but, Kerry, God, it is, Jason, you're right. Kerry, you have done so many, look at how upwell is already. I'm not like, Kerry, you've been listening so far. It's true. It was down, and it was in his tummy. Right, and you just woke him up.
太喜欢了。太喜欢了。我等不及要看了。但是，但是，凯瑞，天哪，杰森，你说得对。凯瑞，你演了那么多，看看威利现在有多精神。我不是那种……凯瑞，你一直都在听。真的。刚才情绪很低落，而且还在他肚子裡。没错，你把他吵醒了。
Yeah, I'm in love. Well, you know what it's like with the little ones, right? So, we just sew little Denny woke up at one, and then he bar him up. Yeah, I'm okay. Well, you know what it's like with the little ones, right? Yeah. So, just so little Denny woke up at one, and then he barfed in his bed, and then he came into our bed, then he barfed in our bed, then we stripped all the sheets.
对，我恋爱了。好吧，你知道照顾小家伙们是什么感觉，对吧？所以，小丹尼一点的时候醒了，然后他吐了。对，我没事。好吧，你知道照顾小家伙们是什么感觉，对吧？对。所以，小丹尼一点的时候醒了，然后在他的床上吐了，接着他来到我们的床上，在我们的床上吐了，然后我们把所有的床单都扒了。
Yeah. It was 115. We're stripping the sheets, and he's on the thing, he's got all those passfiring, and he goes, where are we gonna sleep? Oh!
对。当时是一点十五分。我们在扒床单，他坐在那儿，含着所有那些安抚奶嘴，然后他说，我们今晚要在哪儿睡觉？哦！
Oh! Oh, but I know, I've done that. So you've been there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I know. You can treat them like just like a dog, you know, and put them in a room locked up where you don't appear if he starts crying or yelling or yelling or barking. Yeah. And the throw-up just you can deal with in the morning. Yeah. Yeah. That goes. Where did you sleep, Will? Where did you end up sleeping? Well, we got it was, God, it was a real hodgepodge that all night. I slept on one side of our bed and then Senator took him back to, and was in with his bed.
哦！哦，不过我懂，我也干过。所以你经历过。对。对。对。对。对。对。我知道。你可以像对待一条狗一样对待他们，你知道的，把他们关在一个房间里，如果他开始哭泣、大喊大叫或狂吠，你都不要出现。对。至于呕吐物，你早上再处理就行了。对。对。这就过去了。你睡在哪儿，威利？你最后睡在哪儿了？好吧，我们那晚真是个大杂烩。我睡在我们床的一侧，然后塞纳把他带回去了，跟他一起睡在他的床上。
But one of the good new, one of the good things, and then we'll stop this, we'll get into carries that he learned now, he knows how to throw up in a trap, like in a bucket. Oh, good. He taught him that, and at first he was like, wait, I'm gonna, no, and now he's like, I have to be sick now, and then he goes over and does it.
不过好消息之一，好消息之一，然后我们就不说了，我们要聊聊凯瑞了，那就是他现在学会了，他知道怎么吐在一个容器里，比如一个桶里。哦，太好了。我们教会了他这个，起初他觉得，等等，我要，不，现在他觉得，我现在得生病了，然后他就走过去照做了。
And it's really sweet that he's learned that. So maybe get a pale, he can just kind of put over his head. You know, like a little little handle. I'm gonna just kind of hang surround his head like a necklace. I'm gonna say your parenting tips are really, they're bordering on dangerous, a lot of them. I'm sorry. I'm gonna get the bad next time.
他学会了这一点真的很贴心。所以也许弄个小桶，他可以直接套在头上。你知道的，就像一个小把手。我可以把它挂在他脖子上，像个项链一样。我要说的是，你的育儿建议真的很危险，很多都是。抱歉。我下次会拿个坏的。
So Carrie Mulligan, where are we finding you right now? God, it's great to see you. I'm sorry. I'm at the bad next time. So, Carrie Mulligan, where are we finding you right now? God, it's great to see you. I'm in LA. Oh, right. Yeah. Fantastic. Doing the stuff. Oh, yeah, for the press tour, for the movie.
所以，凯瑞·穆里根，我们现在在哪里能找到你？天哪，很高兴见到你。抱歉。我下次会拿个坏的。所以，凯瑞·穆里根，我们现在在哪里能找到你？天哪，很高兴见到你。我在洛杉矶。哦，对。对。太棒了。在忙着做宣传。哦，对，为了电影的宣传之旅。
Yeah, so our film comes out very soon. So it worked out that we just suddenly went from 0 to 60 and jumped on flights, and so now we're here. Right, because the strike went away, and you could talk about this thing that I'm sure you and Bradley are excited to discuss because it is so damn good. I mean, I think we've all done projects where it's like, oh, now I gotta go talk about
对，我们的电影很快就要上映了。所以一切都很凑巧，我们突然从0加速到60，直接坐上了飞机，所以现在我们在这儿。对，因为罢工结束了，你可以谈论这部作品了，我确信你和布拉德利都很兴奋能聊聊，因为它实在是太棒了。我的意思是，我想我们都拍过这样的项目，当时的感觉是，哦，现在我得去谈谈
how great it is in quotes. Yeah, but this one truly is. I know it's so nice to not have to lie. It's so nice to just... Carrie, can I just say, and again, at the risk of embarrassing you, and people will be able to go and can see Maestro in theaters and then be able to watch on Netflix.
它到底有多么“引号里的”伟大。对，但这部绝对是。我知道，不用撒谎的感觉真好。这种感觉太棒了……凯瑞，我能说吗，冒着让你尴尬的风险，大家可以去影院观看《音乐大师》，然后还可以在网飞上观看。
I, again, I don't want to embarrass you. I think that your performance in Maestro is one of the great performances I've seen in the last 20 years. I really do agree. I agree. I'm so moving and beautiful. And there's some. Sean, you won't get it.
我再次说明，我不想让你尴尬。我认为你在《音乐大师》中的表演是我在过去20年里看到的伟大的表演之一。我真的这么认为。我完全同意。太感人了，太美了。而且还有一些。肖恩，你不会懂的。
I won't get it. Sean won't definitely, Sean won't get it because it's not in space. It's just music, piano, and stuff. And there's some. Sean, you won't get it. I won't get it. Sean won't definitely, Sean won't get it, because it's not in space. It's just music or pianos and stuff and it's. No, for him. But, yeah. Buh, buh, buh, buh. Sean, you're gonna, the music part, Sean,
我不会懂。肖恩绝对不会懂，肖恩绝对不会懂，因为它不在太空中。那只是音乐、钢琴之类的东西。而且还有一些。肖恩，你不会懂的。我不会懂。肖恩绝对不会懂，因为它不在太空中。那只是音乐或钢琴之类的东西，而且。不，对他是。但是，嗯。呃，呃，呃，呃。肖恩，你会，音乐部分，肖恩，
you're gonna, it's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you away. It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away.
你会，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到。它会把你震撼到。它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到。它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到。它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到。它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到。它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到。
It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you. It's gonna blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you. It's gonna blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as done in this film that I, honestly, it's transformative. I hate using the word, because it's so gross, and we all shy away from certain sort of catch phrases that we as actors, or filmmakers, or whatever, often use. I'm not going to say story teller, but you truly are an artist. I really mean that.
它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到。它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到。它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到。它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为的那样，它会把你震撼到，正如你所认为 That's tight second. It is tight second. I'll follow it only by very closely by in the physically doing pre-hands, but truly. So I just want to say that, whatever you do, if there's ever an endorsement that we've ever done in this show, this is one. Please see Carrie Mulligan in my show. Yeah, yeah. I have a question about it because I didn't get, Bradley showed me, like, clips early on, and he invited me to one screen and I couldn't go, but I can't wait to see it, but when you, I've heard only great things like we're saying, when you do a role like that, how much prep
It's tight second. It is tight second. I'll follow it only by very closely by in the physically doing pre-hands, but truly. So I just want to say that, whatever you do, if there's ever an endorsement that we've ever done in this show, this is one. Please see Carrie Mulligan in my show. Yeah, yeah. I have a question about it because I didn't get, Bradley showed me, like, clips early on, and he invited me to one screen and I couldn't go, but I can't wait to see it, but when you, I've heard only great things like we're saying, when you do a role like that, how much prep
这是一个势均力敌的第二名。紧随其后的是实际准备工作的阶段，但确实如此。所以我想说，无论你做什么，如果我们在节目中做过什么推荐，这就是其中之一。请去看我在节目中提到的凯瑞·穆里根。是的，是的。我对此有一个问题，因为我没有看懂，布莱德利很早就给我看了片段，他邀请我去参加一个放映会，但我去不了，但我等不及要看了，但是当你，我只听到像我们所说的那样非常棒的评价，当你演这样一个角色时，需要做多少准备
time do you give yourself? How much work do you put into it before you start day one and how nervous are you in playing such an incredible character on the first day of filming where do you get the confidence like I think I got this are we rolling watch this watch what I'm gonna do with this oh god yeah yeah I don't know I don't I don't I don't I don't think I've had a. I mean, I've had parts, I sort of feel like I've had parts like this on stage, you know, like really, really rich, big kind of sort of something epic about them, parts, but not, like, amazing. I've had such amazing, you know, luck with, with jobs, but on screen, I don't, I'm when he offered it to me, I was shocked, because, first of all, I thought, oh, you think I on screen, I don't, I'm when he offered it to me, I was shocked. Because first of all, I thought,
oh, you think I can act? That's so nice. I think. But secondly, that just, you know, I don't know. It was like, he just saw a star as one. He could have, you know, it was just wild to think, like, oh, gosh, you're trusting me with this. But within that conversation, he said,
you know, if you're gonna do this, you have to go all in, you know, and I thought like, oh, you have to go all in. And I thought, oh God, not all in. You know, but it's not, I've always been a bit like, people keeping their dialect in between scenes and thinking of it. Right. Everyone's got different processes. Yeah. Different definitions of all. Yeah, but then I was like, I think I have to do Bradley's all in, which is, as you will know, like... All in. Yeah, but then I was like, oh, I think I have to do Bradley's all in, which is, as you will know, like.
All in. Yeah, sounds so good when you start. Yeah, and with this one, particularly, he had to be all in, because he not only plays the lead, but also or co-lead, but also wrote it, directed it, produced it. Yeah, that's, it's a lot.
And, Karen, you have to play your character. You, I mean, you and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and go through your life, through this character's life, on this incredible journey, and we see all these different stages, and it's really impressive to watch some, you know, we've, people have done things like that before, but that's no small feat as an actor, to go through that, to track that, to be present in all those different stages of that person's life,
And, Karen, you have to play your character. You, I mean, you and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and,&&走过你的一生，通过这个角色的生活，经历这段不可逆的电影旅程，我们看到了所有这些不同阶段，作为演员要经历这些并进行追踪，在所有这些同一个人生命的不同阶段中保持在场，这真的令人印象深刻，
like I imagine is very difficult as an actor. Yeah, I think it was like Bradley did all the work, you know, he did all the work on his character, I mean, I don't know how he did it. He's some sort of like geniuses, just so crazy, you know, like the script, everything is just mad. So he was ringing me up. I'm sure he was doing this to you.
我想象作为演员这非常困难。是的，我觉得就像布拉德利完成了所有的工作，你知道，他为他的角色完成了所有的工作，我的意思是，我不知道他是怎么做到的。他某种程度上是个天才，简直太疯狂了，你知道，剧本，所有东西都太疯狂了。所以他会打电话给我。我确信他也对你这么做了。
He was ringing me up as Lenny, like two years before we started shooting FaceTiming in character. I mean, it was mad. Oh, wow. You know, I was putting the kids to bed and it would just suddenly be, like, all right, mate, I'm gonna have mate, I'm gonna put later bird signs on the phone But you know, yeah, he's just so I feel like
他在我们开拍前大约两年就以伦尼的身份打电话给我，通过FaceTime用角色的状态交流。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。哦，哇。你知道的，我当时在哄孩子们睡觉，然后电话里突然就变成这样，好了，伙计，我要，伙计，我等会儿要给鸟发信号，但是你知道，是的，他就是这样，所以我觉得
And so then I got into it really early as well because I signed on in like 2018 and we didn't shoot till 2022 So I had you know time and I had an opportunity to to sort of really kind of Do lots of of what we narrated not put together in Philadelphia, one of his operas. So we did so much that by the time we got onto that, we did this sort of mad dream workshop thing, I'm sure he told you about what we sort of spent a week together crying a lot. And so by the time we got there, it was one of the first, maybe the first time I didn't feel completely terrified on day one, because I sort of felt like, you know, we've kind of got... You know, we've kind of got our thing, and he just...
所以我也很早就进入了状态，因为我在2018年左右就签约了，而我们直到2022年才开始拍摄，所以我有，你知道的，时间，我也有机会真正地，做很多我们叙述的事情，没有在费城排练他的其中一部歌剧。所以我们做了很多准备，以至于当我们开始的时候，我们进行了这种疯狂的梦境工作坊，我确信他跟你提过我们是怎么花了一周时间在一起大哭的。所以当我们到那儿的时候，那是我第一天可能第一次没有感到完全恐惧，因为我某种程度上觉得，你知道，我们有点……你知道，我们有我们自己的东西了，而且他……
You know, he made it so that you could just basically do anything, and it didn't matter, and that was so fun. One of the things that I love about your abilities is that you... Every character you play, you're so sort of, it seems in touch with kind of their internal stuff. And you're really doing, you can really feel your character thinking and feeling before they're talking, before they're performing, before they're doing anything physical. That is something that's fairly, That is something that's fairly, it's much easier to capture on film
你知道，他让你觉得你基本上可以做任何事，而且这都无所谓，这太有趣了。我喜欢你的能力的一点是，你……你扮演的每一个角色，你都非常，似乎与她们内心的东西保持着联系。你真的在做，你真的能感觉到你的角色在说话之前、在表演之前、在做任何形体动作之前都在思考和感受。那是某种相当……那是某种相当……在电影中更容易捕捉到，
because camera is close to you, it can be, but on stage, you often have to consider the person in the back row too. Tell me about the difference in process and all of a sudden I don't want to put the audience to sleep, but was that a difficult thing for you to kind of calibrate and modulate as you went from theater into film because you're so small and subtle in film in a great way. Yet I'm sure you can't really do that on stage
因为镜头离你很近，可以这样，但在舞台上，你通常也得考虑到最后一排的人。跟我讲讲流程上的区别，突然之间我不想让观众听睡着了，但从戏剧转到电影时，去校准和调节这些对你来说是一件很难的事吗？因为你在电影中表现得非常细微和微妙，这很棒。然而我确信你在舞台上真的不能那样做
and still be as effective. It's weird, because I kind of had to reverse engineering, because my first job was a film, I had done lots I mean I was never going to be like a musical theater was what I wanted to do. Really? Okay. Oh, Sean just woke up. I know. I'm pointing at his little box. Which ones and we'll go through them all. Okay, so we so we so I didn't really kind of so I did Pride and Prejudice. That was my first job and I played this little, you know,
还能同样有效。这很奇怪，因为我有点不得不逆向工程，因为我的第一份工作是一部电影，我做过很多，我的意思是，我从没想过要做音乐剧，那是我当时想做的。真的吗？好吧。哦，肖恩刚醒。我知道。我正指着他的小方框。哪一个，我们会把它们都过一遍。好吧，所以我们，所以我们——所以我其实没有——所以我演了《傲慢与偏见》。那是我的第一份工作，我演了这个小小的，你知道，
I played one of the Bennett sisters and just ran around, Jenna Malone for the whole summer, like, you know, giggling. And then I went to the Royal Court of Theatre and did my first play straight afterwards and that was like a real, you know, and I didn't train, I didn't go to drama school so I felt completely unqualified to do any of it.
我演了班内特家的一个姐妹，整个夏天都在和詹娜·马拉松到处跑，你知道的，咯咯地笑。然后我去了皇家宫廷剧院，紧接着排了我的第一部戏剧，那是一次真正的，你知道的，而且我没有受过训练，我没上过戏剧学校，所以我觉得自己完全没有资格做这一切。
So I sort of, I think I just sort of learned from the job, but I think I only ever found the difference being and reaching the back of the room with my voice, not with my anything else. So I didn't really think I did module anything and maybe that's not, but I've always, but I've also only played like maximum of 1000 seats.
所以我有点，我想我只是从工作中学习，但我认为我唯一发现的区别在于用声音传达到房间的最后排，而不是靠其他任何东西。所以我真的不认为我做过任何调节，也许事实并非如此，但我一直以来，而且我也只在最多1000个座位的场馆演出过。
But you definitely had a trust that people were getting it. We're seeing it. You were communicating with the audience. And how did you get that trust, that confidence, that feeling without having gone through any sort of training or any sort of practicing or education in it? What gave you the sense that you were good at acting and that you knew what you were doing
但你肯定有一种信任，觉得人们能get到。我们看到了。你在与观众交流。在你没有经历过任何训练、练习或教育的情况下，你是如何获得那种信任、自信和感觉的？是什么给你这种感觉，让你觉得你擅长表演，你知道自己在做什么，
that you were capable of it? I don't know if I got, I mean, I just, I feel like I just got, I got a really great part when I was, when I was 21, I got to play Nina and the Seagull in at the Royal Court in London and, and I worked with an amazing cast on that, and the, and that character's just the, it's the most, it's sort of what I mean about, you know, not getting to play a part like Felicia on screen. You know, that's Nina is sort of that kind of role, you know. She really goes from this innocent young kind of naive, wannabe star to someone who is completely kind of destroyed by her experiences by the end of the breadth of her experience. It's just so amazing.
并且你有能力做到这一点？我不知道我是否得到了，我的意思是，我只是，我觉得我只是得到了，自我21岁起，我就得到了一个非常棒的角色，我有机会在伦敦的皇家宫廷剧院出演《海鸥》中的妮娜，我和一个出色的演员阵容合作了这部戏，那个角色简直就是，这是最棒的，这有点像我刚才说的（在银幕上没有机会扮演像菲莉西亚这样的角色）。你知道，妮娜就是那种角色。她真的从一个无辜、年轻、天真、渴望成名的明星，变成了在经历结束时被她的经历彻底摧毁的人，她经历的广度真是太惊人了。
Yeah. We'll be right back. Smartless. Get support from Sonos. Picture this. Your favorite tunes and movies, but this time, it's like you're right there. How? Thanks to the Sonos, Aura, 300's groundbreaking spatial audio. Aura 300 is a mid-tier, all-in-one plugin, smart speaker designed for immersive sound
我们马上回来。SmartLess。获取Sonos的支持。想象一下。你最喜欢的曲调和电影，但这一次，感觉就像你身临其境。怎么做到的？多亏了Sonos Era 300突破性的空间音频。Era 300是一款中端一体式即插即用智能扬声器，旨在提供身临其境的声音
and spatial audio listening out loud. When played through compatible devices, spatial audio allows you to feel like the music and sound is all around, you fully immersing you into the content. But here's the real game changer. Using two Aera 300s as Dolby Atmos home theater rears when paired with Ark or Beam.
和外放空间音频聆听体验。当通过兼容设备播放时，空间音频能让你感觉音乐和声音环绕在四周，让你完全沉浸在内容中。但真正的改变者在这里。当与Arc或Beam搭配时，使用两个Era 300作为杜比全景声家庭影院后置扬声器。
It's like having your own private cinema right at home. The depth and clarity add a whole new dimension to movie nights. And it's not just about sound. The Aero 300 packs a punch in features too, with Wi-Fi, Bluetooth, and USB-C connectivity. It seamlessly fits into your tech life. Now, I got myself an Air 300 and gang, you know when you're in your house
这就像在家拥有你自己的私人影院。深度和清晰度为电影之夜增添了全新的维度。这不仅仅关乎声音。Era 300在功能上也毫不逊色，支持Wi-Fi、Bluetooth和USB-C连接。它无缝融入你的科技生活。现在，我给自己搞了一个Era 300，伙计们，你知道当你呆在家里，
and you hear a little sound and you look over your shoulder like, who's there? What's going on? Because you're like looking around like, what's going on? How is the sound all around me? I'm freaking out, bros.
听到一点声音，然后回过头去看，就像，谁在那儿？怎么回事？因为你就像环顾四周一样，问怎么回事？为什么声音都在我四周？我吓坏了，兄弟们。
I don't know how the tech works, but it's pretty awesome sauce. Head over to sonos.com and enjoy up to 20% of most wanted speakers and sets. Offer valid through December 18th or wall supplies blast. SmartList is sponsored by ADT. Now ADT professionally installs Google Nest products so your home is safe and smart. You can check in on your home and manage your security system from virtually anywhere. With Nest Cams and the Nest Doorbell, you can even get intelligent alerts so you've received notifications on what matters most. Google Nest Cams can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle,
我不知道这技术是怎么运作的，但它真的很棒。前往sonos.com，享受最受欢迎的扬声器和套装高达20%的优惠。优惠有效期至12月18日或售完即止。SmartList由ADT赞助。现在ADT专业安装Google Nest产品，让您的家安全又智能。您可以随时随地查看您的家并管理您的安全系统。通过Nest相机和Nest门铃，您甚至可以获得智能警报，以便收到关于最重要事情的通知。Google Nest相机可以分辨出人、动物、车辆的区别，
or with the Nest doorbell, even a package. And with Nest aware, as part of your monthly ADT service, you get 30 days of event, video history, and even smarter notifications, like when a familiar or unfamiliar face is seen. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view video of an alarm event or verify or cancel on alarm with just a tap.
或者通过Nest门铃，甚至能分辨出包裹。作为每月ADT服务的一部分，通过Nest Aware，您可以获得30天的事件视频历史记录，甚至更智能的通知，例如何时看到熟悉或陌生的面孔。此外，当每一秒都很重要时，您可以信赖ADT的24/7专业监控。只需轻轻一按，即可查看警报事件的视频，或验证或取消警报。
When the most trusted name in home security adds the intelligence of Google, you've got a home with no worries. Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP. Google, Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nest Aware are trademarks of Google LLC. Thank you to Macy's for supporting this episode of SmartLess. It's the season of giving and Macy's is making it even more delightful for any of you down to the wire shoppers. They're still time to find the perfect gift at Macy's last minute gift sale. Now until Saturday, December 23rd get an extra 20% off great gifts, including the latest wardrobe updates,
当家庭安全中最值得信赖的名字融入Google的智能技术时，您的家将变得无忧无虑。今天就访问ADT.com或致电1-800-ADT-ASAP。Google、Nest Cam、Nest Doorbell和Nest Aware是Google LLC的商标。感谢Macy's梅西百货支持本期SmartLess。这是送礼的季节，梅西百货让所有赶在最后关头的购物者更加开心。在梅西百货的最后关头礼品促销中，仍然有时间找到完美的礼物。从现在到12月23日星期六，精选好礼可享额外8折优惠，包括最新的服装更新、
makeup and skincare sets, the season's hottest toys and everything else on their wish list. With such a wide array of options, you'll find something for everyone, including a little something for yourself. So hurry, slay the gift game with Macy's last minute gift sale. The countdown to joy is on. Check out Macy's.com and use promo code gift to save today. One more time. That is code gift at macy's.com. Some exclusions apply. See macy's.com for details. All right, back to the show. But what, what, I like this equation. I was like, what gave you the guts to do this?
彩妆和护肤套装、本季最热门的玩具以及他们心愿单上的其他一切。拥有如此广泛的选择，你会为每个人找到合适的东西，甚至包括犒劳你自己的小礼物。所以快来吧，用梅西百货的最后一刻礼品促销来制霸送礼游戏吧。欢乐倒计时已经开始。请访问 Macys.com 并使用促销代码 gift 现已开始省钱。再说一遍。这就是 macy's.com 上的代码 gift。某些限制适用。详情请参见 macy's.com。好了，回到节目中。但是，什么，什么，我喜欢这个公式。我想，是什么给了你这样做的勇气？
I was, I was trying to get to the place of life. No, she's too humble to say, but that it's natural for you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I know I'm joking because yeah, that's right. It is natural for you. And kind of like Sean, No, no, I was going to say Jason, you touched on it, but in reference to what you had said, Kerry, that you said that you didn't go to drama school or anything.
我当时，我当时正试图到达人生的那个阶段。不，她太谦虚了不好意思说，但这对于你来说是自然而然的。是的，是的，是的。不，我知道我在开玩笑，因为是的，没错。这对你来说确实是自然而然的。就像肖恩一样，不，不，我要说的是杰森，你提到了这一点，但是关于你刚才说的，凯瑞，你说你没有去过戏剧学校或类似的地方。
And yet you lived or you worked in this environment that very much there is a sort of hierarchy in that way because in this sort of the English acting and performing community, if you didn't go to Rada or if you didn't go whatever, there's like kind of like, hmm, who are you a little bit? And you must have felt, and tell me, I'm asking you, did you ever feel like an outsider in that way?
然而你生活或工作在这个环境中，这里的确存在一种阶层感，因为在英国这种表演和演艺界，如果你没有去过皇家戏剧艺术学院（Rada）或者没有去过别的什么地方，就会有一种“嗯，你算老几”的感觉。你一定有这种感觉，告诉我，我是在问你，你有没有觉得自己在那种意义上像个局外人？
And that you had to work extra hard to prove that you were just as good as a lot of these sort of fops who came out of people who came out of drama school? Oh, yeah. I mean, mean, the first play I did professionally was Straight Off the Pride and Prejudice. And the director had to, so the first preview, they were all, all the cast went into this room to go and warm up. And I could hear it, because they had the little speaker thing
而且你不得不付出额外的努力来证明，你和那些从戏剧学校出来的人一样优秀吗？哦，是的。我的意思是，我职业生涯演的第一部舞台剧就是直接参演《傲慢与偏见》。导演不得不，所以第一次预演时，他们都在，所有的演员都进了一个房间去热身。我能听到，因为那里有一个小型扬声器设备
on it, I could hear it, and my dressing room, and they were all like, oh, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, you know, doing all the weird, like, I thought, fuck in hell, like, I'm not. I'm in my whole body just like, closed, I just thought, I'm not doing that, not doing that. And the director, Katie Mitchell, literally came into the room and she physically moved me
听到这个，在我的化妆间里，他们都在那儿废话连篇，你知道的，做各种奇怪的事，当时我想，操蛋的，我才不呢。我整个人都抗拒了，我只觉得，我才不干那事，才不呢。然后导演凯蒂·米歇尔真的走进了房间，她亲手把我
into that room and sort of just sat me on the floor and was like, just try. And I just sat there going, oh, God, this is so fucking embarrassing, I can't. No, no, no, no, no, no. But I think maybe towards the end of that, I started feeling a bit more comfortable. It's just sort of felt like, not just embarrassing,
移到了那个房间里，差不多就是把我按在地上坐下，然后说，就试一下。我就坐在那儿想，天呐，这太他妈尴尬了，我做不到。不，不，不，不，不，不。但我想可能到那快结束的时候，我开始觉得稍微舒服了一点。感觉不仅仅是尴尬，
but also like, I look like such a tit. I don't know what I'm, you know, any noises that I make and not the noises you're meant to make, or, you know, but it was funny because that's what I'm saying. Right, we're going to look at you and go like, what noises are you? Yeah, that's correct. We're making these ridiculous.
而且还觉得自己看起来像个大笨蛋。我不知道自己在干嘛，你知道的，我发出的任何声音都不是你该发出的声音，或者，你知道的，但这就很滑稽，因为这就是我说的。对，我们会看着你然后想，你发出的都是什么声音？对，没错。我们在发出这些荒谬的声音。
Yeah, and they were like, but they were like, right, right. I could fire doing Shakespeare monologues and I, you know, it was just sort of, but somehow by the time I got to New York, we did the Seagull in London and we did the Seagull in New York. And in New York, Zoe Kazan played Masha, and we became best friends in the world. And we used to go down stage on every night, and we would just sing, do you hear the people sing from Layma Zoroahblit on stage?
是的，他们就觉得，但他们就觉得，对的，对的。我本可以充满激情地朗诵莎士比亚独白，而且我，你知道的，那只是有点像，但不知怎么的，等我到了纽约，我们在伦敦演了《海鸥》，我们在纽约也演了《海鸥》。在纽约，佐伊·卡赞饰演玛莎，我们成了世界上最好的朋友。我们每天晚上都会走到台前，直接唱起，你在台下听到人们在唱歌吗，来自《悲惨世界》里的歌？
And that was our warm up. Yeah. So you're... That was your honor. That's good that you have at least. That became the thing that, you know, that... So that I made my own weird noise, but, yeah, so I think by the time I did that, I felt like, oh, I kind of, not that I'm like, but I felt
那就是我们的热身。是的。所以你是……那是你的荣誉。你至少有这个挺好的。这就成了那件，你知道的，那件事……所以我发出了我自己的奇怪声音，但是，是的，所以我认为等我做完那个的时候，我觉得，哦，我有点，倒不是说我像，但我感觉
comfortable that I would relax a bit. And did you feel part of the club? Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry,
很自在，整个人放松了一点。你觉得自己融入这个圈子了吗？抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉
sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, you kind of feel like, okay, I've now carved out my own sort of path, and I don't have to worry about that other sort of stuff again.
抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，你会有点觉得，好吧，我现在已经开辟了自己的道路，以后不用再担心那种乱七八糟的事了。
I don't have my own sound. So, so, I mean, yeah, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, I think I just, yeah, I all felt kind of fluky for a while, and but I still didn't feel, I mean, definitely went in face, or I felt like completely, I loved just doing all the prep and all that, and feeling like completely immersed in the whole thing film, I always felt like, hello, you know, just,
我没有我自己的风格。所以，所以，我是说，对，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，我觉得我只是，对，我有一段时间觉得一切都像是撞大运，但我觉得我还是没有，我是说，绝对是直面它，或者我觉得完全，我喜欢做所有的准备工作以及所有这些，感觉完全沉浸在整部电影里，我总是觉得，嗨，你知道，只是，
I'm sorry, sorry, don't mean to just... Just passing through. Like, you stand in front of the camera and sort of... What about, but an education, right? That was, was that that kind of the first thing that really kind of pushed you out into? I mean, it was an Academy Award nomination, right? Did it, was the, was the change in climate?
不好意思，不好意思，不是故意要……只是路过。就像，你站在镜头前，然后……那《成长教育》呢？那是，那是真正把你推向大众的第一部作品吗？我是说，那是一次奥斯卡提名，对吧？那次，环境的变化……
Was it, was it palpable for you? Was it, was that an exciting thing or a nerve-wracking thing? Because a bunch of really cool stuff followed that. No, yeah, that was totally, I mean, that was, that was a five-week shoot or something. And I thought maybe it would be on in a couple of really cool stuff followed that. No, yeah, that was totally. I mean, that was a five-week shoot or something, and I thought maybe it would be on in a couple of cinemas, and I had no expectations for that at all, and then we went to Sundance,
对你来说是显而易见的吗？那是一件让人兴奋的事，还是让人紧张的事？因为在那之后发生了很多非常酷的事情。不，是的，完全是，我是说，那是一个为期五周左右的拍摄。我以为它可能只会在几家……随后发生了很多非常酷的事情。不，是的，完全是。我是说，那是一个为期五周左右的拍摄，我以为它可能只会在几家电影院上映，我对它没有任何期望，然后我们去了圣丹斯，
and it kind of turned into this thing. So, yeah, it was a big shift. And I think, I regret not having as much fun as I should have done. I think I took it all quite seriously, and was quite, and had a real imposter syndrome. You know, I'd be in Rome just thinking, like, what the actual crime do I do?
它就变成了一件大事。所以，是的，这是一个巨大的转变。而且我觉得，我后悔没有尽情享受我本该享受的乐趣。我觉得我把它看得太严肃了，而且相当，并且有着强烈的冒出综合征。你知道，我在罗马时，心里总是想，我到底凭什么在这里？
Well, is that, did that come from a sense of, oh my God, what I always hoped would happen is, it seems like it's about to start, or was it, I had no plans whatsoever, this was kind of fun, and now this has happened, and now I'm expected to kind of make a career of this, and be some big fancy actor. No, I think I definitely was all I wanted to do,
好吧，那是，那是源于一种“天哪，我一直希望发生的事情似乎要开始了”的心态，还是“我原本没有任何计划，这挺好玩的，而现在这事发生了，现在大家期望我把这当成职业，成为某个了不起的大明星”？不，我觉得这绝对是我唯一想做的事，
but I think that was, in my mind, I was thinking, okay, good, right, I can get another job. You know, it was that, it was like, this is great, because then, you know, the good part is that the directors are gonna see this, you know? And I'll bet you still feel like that, right? Oh, God, off, yeah. Off this, this, this profession, there's just no guarantees.
但我认为那是，在我的脑海里，我在想，好吧，很好，对，我可以接到下一份工作了。你知道，就是那种，这太棒了，因为这样，你知道，好处是导演们会看到这个，你知道吗？我敢说你现在还是这种感觉，对吧？哦，天哪，绝对是。对于，对于，这个行业，根本没有任何保证。
Yeah. No idea whether you're gonna be working 12 months or so. Well, I was gonna, yeah, I was gonna ask that, Carrie, like, now with all of the incredible work that you've done, isn't there some sense of like, okay, I think I can, I think I'll be working, or does that never go away? I don't know. I just think, I think you always sort of,, okay, I think I can, I think I'll be working, or does that never go away? I don't know. I just think, I think you always sort of, you know, you're always hoping that that one person sees it and then wants to hire you. Do you know what I mean? Like, you always feel
是啊。完全不知道你接下来12个月或者什么时候还有没有工作。好吧，我正想说，凯莉，就像你现在有了这么多不可思议的作品，难道没有那种“好吧，我想我能，我想我会有工作”的感觉吗，还是说这种感觉永远不会消失？我不知道。我只是觉得，我觉得你总是会有一种……“好吧，我想我能，我想我会有工作”，还是说这种感觉永远不会消失？我不知道。我只是觉得，你总是会，你知道，你总是希望那个人看到它，然后想要雇佣你。你知道我的意思吗？就像，你总是会觉得
or that it's to someone's taste. I don't think it ever does go away. Do you watch your stuff? Do you watch your... Do you know the only thing I've watched is my story? It's funny, because I don't really. Really? No, no, no. I've never seen, like, she said that came out last year. I saw promising young woman once. Yeah, you should check it out. Is it because you get self-conscious? Like, do you watch playback on set? No, no, no, no, no. No.
或者觉得这正合某人的口味。我不觉得这种感觉会消失。你看你自己的作品吗？你看你的……你知道我唯一看过的是我的故事。这很有趣，因为我其实不看。真的吗？不，不，不。我从来没看过，比如她去年上映的那部。我只看了一次《前程似锦的年轻女子》。对，你应该去看看。是因为你会感到不自然吗？比如你在片场会看回放吗？不，不，不，不，不。不。
No, it fucks me up completely. No, I can't. I can't look at anything and I can't look at stills. I can't look at... Although, but Bradley was so like... You know, he wanted us to sort of have a sense of what we were making all the time. So I did, I watched that with him and I've watched a couple cuts of, I haven't seen the final, final cut of my story yet. But I will, and I want to, but with most things now, I just... The progression of it is amazing. I mean, it was the first cut I saw was already incredible, but the way he shaped it kept moving it, it never went backwards. It was always, and he's just, he's a great filmmaker.
不，那会把我彻底搞崩溃。不，我什么都看不了，我也看不了剧照。我不能看……不过，布莱德利真的很……你知道，他希望我们一直对我们正在创作的东西有一种感觉。所以我跟他一起看了那个，我也看过几个剪辑版，我还没看过《音乐大师》的最终剪辑版。但我会看的，我也想看，但对于现在的大多数事情，我只是……它的进展太神奇了。我是说，我看到的第一个剪辑版就已经不可思议了，但他塑造它的方式一直在推动它前进，它从未倒退。它一直在向前，而且他，他是一位伟大的电影制作人。
Yeah, he is. I feel very privileged that you never watched anything and then I got to watch my show with you then. Yeah, yeah. And my husband watched it as well. And he, he's watched it now twice and he's done. He doesn't like the sad parts. He can't watch the sad parts.
是的，他是。我觉得很荣幸，你从来不看任何东西，然后我却能跟你一起看我的节目。对，对。我丈夫也看了。而且他，他现在已经看了两遍，他看够了。他不喜欢悲伤的部分。他看不了悲伤的部分。
Yeah, of course. It must be. Yeah, it was so fun meeting you guys and meeting Marcus. Obviously tell us a little bit. I mean, you're married to, like Jason said, you're married to a rock star. I was like, it's so funny. Marcus Muffered and Sons.
对，当然。那一定很。是的，很高兴能认识你们和马库斯。显然给我们讲讲。我是说，你嫁给了一个，就像杰森说的，你嫁给了一个摇滚明星。我当时就想，这太有趣了。马库斯·蒙福德与之子乐队（Marcus Mumford and Sons）。
Yeah, Muffered. I did it at the rock star thing, always sounds like, well, you're married to a rock star. I was like, it's so funny. Marcus Mufferd and Sons. Yeah, I did the rock star thing always sounds so. I'm like, well, it's true. Yeah, it is. Well, you know, you must have, did you meet him Jason when you were doing the video? You did the video. I don't think we met that day, but I met you guys at Austin City Limits.
对，蒙福德。我一听到“摇滚明星”这个词，总是觉得，好吧，你嫁给了一个摇滚明星。我当时就想，这太有趣了。马库斯·蒙福德与之子乐队。对，我一听到摇滚明星这个词总是觉得……我心想，好吧，这是真的。对，确实是。好吧，你知道，你一定是在你拍MV的时候认识他的吗？你拍了那个MV。我觉得我们那天没见面，但我是在奥斯汀城市音乐节（Austin City Limits）上认识你们的。
Oh, yeah. At one point, I was there for a radio head show, I want to say. And that was really, really cool. Yeah, we had a blast, too. And that was a, we did a video. You know, Sam Jones directed that. Sam Jones directed the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
哦，对。有一次，我在那儿看电台司令（Radio Head）的演出，我想是的。那真的非常非常酷。对，我们当时也玩得很嗨。而且那是一个，我们拍了一个MV。你知道，萨姆·琼斯（Sam Jones）导演的那个。萨姆·琼斯导演了那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个我当时在里面，还有埃德·赫姆斯（Ed Helms）。埃德·赫姆斯，对。他们扮演这个乐队。
the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, it was me, and it was Ed Helms. Ed Helms, yeah. And they've played the band.
他们就是那个乐队。带有一种非常滑稽的风格，我们在做一些，就像我们是乐队在某个谷仓里拍MV，我们在弹奏乐器。就得这样。就像，是的，弹奏一堆胡闹的东西。对，有些荒谬又搞笑。对，我喜欢。我喜欢。当杰伊模仿那种声音时，你知道的，因为太棒了。那就是，那是喜剧效果，就是我们，你知道，只是
They were the band. And in a very campy sort of, we're doing some, like we were the band shooting a video out and some barn and we were playing our instruments. Bound to. Just like, yeah, playing a bunch of grab ass. Yeah, it was some ridiculous and hilarious. Yeah, I love it. I love it. When Jay goes into that voice, you know, because it was amazing. That was that was the comedic, just was that we're, you know, just
只是一群乡巴佬在弹吉他，玩得很开心。对。凯莉，在你认识他之前，你对音乐也这么感兴趣吗？还是说，你是，或者说，在你认识他之后这种兴趣才高涨的？我们当时就像，哦，在我面前弹吉他。我想知道它是怎么运作的。就像，还是你之前没有做这种准备？在你面前弹你的吉他。我一直很喜欢，我是说，你知道，我想演音乐剧。
just a bunch of Hicks playing, playing guitar and having a good time. Yeah. Do you, were you, Carrie, were you as interested in music before you met him? Or were you, like, or was it, did it heightened after you met? We were like, oh, play the guitar in front of me. I want to know how it works. Like, or did you not prepare that early? On your guitar in front of you. I always loved, I mean, you know, I wanted to do musical theater.
我喜欢音乐剧和所有诸如此类的东西。不是从小就……你是说？我能，我像唱诗班一样，我能唱唱诗班的歌，你知道，想演音乐剧。我喜欢音乐剧和所有诸如此类的东西，不是从小就……你是说？我能，我像唱诗班一样，我能唱唱诗班的歌，你知道，我唱得足够在调上，但没好到可以去演音乐剧的地步。所以我才会转行去演纯正的戏剧。但我没有，我记得看过马克斯的乐队。好吧，我们是朋友，我们当时还是孩子，所以我们一起去过夏令营。
I loved musicals and all those sorts of things. It was not a growing up. Are you saying? I can, I'm like a choir, I can choir sing, you know, wanted to do musical theater. I loved musicals and all those sort of things was not growing up. Are you saying? I can, I'm like a choir, I can choir sing, you know, I can sing enough to hold a tune, but not good enough to do musical theater. So that's why I kind of swerved into just straight acting. But I didn't, I remember seeing Marx's band. Well, we were friends and we were kids, so we went to camp together.
哦，哇。等等，等等，等等，你们当时在玩过家家，对吧？对。等等，什么？对。我知道。所以我们一起去了夏令营。哦，哇，等等，等等，等等，等等，你们是笔友，对吧？对，等等，什么？对，你们是笔友，我们一起去过夏令营，我们见面的时候
Oh wow. Wait, wait, wait, wait, you guys were playing the house, right? Yeah. Wait, what? Yeah. I know. So we went to camp together. Oh wow wait wait wait wait wait wait you guys were Pen-pals right yeah wait what yeah your pen pals we went to camp together we met when He was ten. I was twelve. Yeah, yeah, we met when we were kids and we guys hook up then We didn't but I do I'd wrote in my diary that he was The nicest the kindest person I'd ever met and I gave him 9.5 out of 10. Wow! What a score! I know! But I said, all score, what score would you give him today? He's getting out there, I'd give him a solid six, but he's the...
他十岁。我十二岁。对，对，我们很小的时候就认识了，然后你们当时勾搭上了吗？我们没有，但我确实，我在日记里写过，他是见过的最好、最善良的人，我给他打了9.5分（满分10分）。哇！好高的分！我知道！但我说，所有分，你现在会给他打几分？他现在嘛，我给他一个稳稳的6分，但他这个人……
Yeah, and I also wrote in my diary that he definitely wasn't boyfriend material. I mean, not that I'd ever had a boyfriend at that time, but I decided that he was not it. That's so crazy that you knew each other. That's crazy. And I am worried. And you stayed pen pals for a while? Well, pen pals were a couple years and we lost touch. Then the internet happened and
对，我还在日记里写了，他绝对不是男朋友的材料。我是说，倒不是说我那时候交过男朋友，但我当时就断定他不是那块料。你们俩竟然从小就认识，太疯狂了。太疯狂了。而且我很担心。你们当了一段时间的笔友？好吧，当了几年笔友，然后我们失去了联系。后来互联网出现了，
we got the internet happened. And we started, we were both on Facebook for like six months, then we both left, so we touched base there briefly. And then we met again, yeah, when I was like 24. And at that point, you guys were like, this is, I mean, we keep running into each other. We are destined to be together. We're probably, we should get married, yeah. Wow.
我们，互联网出现了。我们开始，我们都在脸书（Facebook）上待了大约六个月，然后我们都退出了，所以我们在那里简单地联系过。然后我们又见面了，对，当我24岁的时候。那时候，你们俩就觉得，这个，我是说，我们一直偶遇对方。我们注定要在一起。我们可能，我们应该结婚，对吧。哇。
Did you guys ever have any conversations about how crazy is it that we both ended up doing public jobs and finding a really incredible level of success? Well, what's weird is that we also, not long after we met again as adults, we both worked on the Coen Brothers movie inside Lewand Davis and both independently were hired. Oh, hello, Rumi. Sorry, someone's just come in, J This is the high. Should we hold? Hi. Is it a roommate? Just say hi.
你们有没有聊过，我们俩最终都从事了公众瞩目的工作，并且都达到了非常了不起的成功水平，这有多疯狂？好吧，奇怪的是，我们还，在我们作为成年人再次相遇后不久，我们都参演了科恩兄弟的电影《醉乡民谣》，而且都是各自独立被雇用的。哦，你好，鲁米。抱歉，有人刚进来，杰，这是嗨。我们要暂停一下吗？嗨。是室友吗？打个招呼吧。
Hi, I can't hear you. Oh my god. Hi guys. Hey really? Hi. Listen, we live together. We have yesterday's guest sitting right next to today's guest. No, I'm a how are you feeling?
嗨，我听不见你说话。哦，天哪。嗨，各位。嘿，真的吗？嗨。听着，我们住在一起。我们把昨天的嘉宾安排在紧挨着今天的嘉宾旁边。不，我，你感觉怎么样？
I'm getting better. Are you? Very, very sweet to let me be so close to her when she doesn't. The week we are across the whole from each other. Oh, that's a terrible. Did you get the chicken noodle soup? I got the chicken noodle soup, Sean. I didn't know how to reach out to you.
我好多了。是吗？真是太贴心了，让我离她这么近，虽然她并不……我们住在走廊的两端。哦，那太糟糕了。你喝到鸡汤了吗？我喝到鸡汤了，肖恩。我都不知道怎么联系你。
Oh, you're half due. This is the best. I have to show you a picture of it as it came up for the room. One second. Sorry, I'm not. I'm going away. She was sitting, selling center over some chicken noodle soup. I knew you would. When you said that you were going to, I knew going away. She was sick, so I sent her over some chicken noodle soup. I knew you would.
哦，你已经好了一半了。这太棒了。我得给你看看它端进房间时的照片。等一下。抱歉，我不是。我要走开。她当时正坐在那儿，喝着一些鸡汤。我就知道你会。当你说了你要去……我要走开。她生病了，所以我让人给她送了些鸡汤。我就知道你会。
When you said that you were going to, I knew you would. You didn't say that. This is how it arrives. Oh God. It was like a ball of sec. It does look like a ball of sec. That's what it looks like. It looks like it was somebody barf. Oh no, it's short of like this. What's the other note? All that is sweet.
当你说了你要去的时候，我就知道你会。你才没说呢。这是它送来的样子。哦，天哪。这看起来像一团呕吐物。它确实看起来像一团呕吐物。看起来就是那样。看起来就像有人吐成一团。哦，不，它有点像这样。另一个纸条是什么？所有这些都很甜美。
It looks like a ball of sec. Yeah, it does look like a ball of sec. That's what it looks like. It was somebody barfed in a ball. I'm glad you didn't put our names on it, Sean. Where was it from, Sean? They're saying it looks like he barfed in a ball. It's like I barfed in a ball.
它看起来像一团呕吐物。是的，它确实看起来像一团呕吐物。看起来就是那样。就像有人吐成了一团。肖恩，我很高兴你没在上面写我们的名字。是从哪儿来的，肖恩？他们说这看起来像他吐成了一团。就像我吐成了一团一样。
I loved it. Thank you, Sean. Sean, was it just from Room Service? Yeah, I think so. I check your bill, because he might have just put it on your bill. All right. I think so. Yeah. Check your bill because he might have just put it on your bill. Okay, bye guys. Bye bye.
我很喜欢。谢谢你，肖恩。肖恩，这是客房送餐服务送的吗？对，我想是的。你查一下账单，因为他可能直接记在你的账单上了。好的。我想是的。对。检查一下你的账单，因为他可能直接记在你的账单上了。好的，拜拜，各位。拜拜。
I'll be back in 20 minutes. Okay, I'll see you guys in a minute. Bye bye bye bye. That's a pretty money. She's not in for me now. She's just talked her two days ago. I know. I was like, I'm nervous.
我20分钟后回来。好的，一会儿见，各位。拜拜拜拜。这挺划算的。她现在可不是为了我来的。她两天才刚说过她。我知道。我当时就想，我很紧张。
You're not nervous anymore. No, I'm fine now. You know what? I wanted to know because we haven't done this part of the, of the, of the, of the, of the, I know, I know. I was like, I'm nervous. So you're not never getting more. No, I'm fine now. You know what? I wanted to know, because we haven't done this part of the interview process yet.
你现在不紧张了。不，我现在挺好的。你知道吗？我想知道，因为我们还没做过采访的这一部分，这一部分，这一部分，这一部分，这一部分，我知道，我知道。我当时就想，我很紧张。所以你现在不紧张了吧。不，我现在很好。你知道吗？我想知道，因为我们还没经历过面试过程的这一部分。
How did we talked about you doing, you know, Pride and Prejudice and doing all these things. But what was the thing that, how did you start? What was your thing where you went like, oh, this is what I want to do? Do you know, it's so funny. I said this to Kevin Bacon the other night. I was in, I was at this like, oh, this is what I want to do. You know, it's so funny. I said this to Kevin Bacon the other night. I was in, I was at this like,
我们谈过你演过，你知道的，1812与偏见（傲慢与偏见）以及所有这些事情。但最初是什么事，你是怎么开始的？是什么事情让你觉得，“哦，这正是我想要做的”？你知道，这太有趣了。我前几天对凯文·培根（Kevin Bacon）说过这个。我当时在，我当时在那个……“哦，这正是我想要做的”。你知道，这太有趣了。我前几天对凯文·培根说过这个。我当时在，我当时在那个……
taste makery, you know? Yeah, sure. In New York for my sister, and he came with his lovely wife, and they came over to say, in that they liked the film, and I said, you know, you're literally, it was seeing you do this one man show in New York, but it was the trip that I, so I was about 14, I went to New York with my mum
潮流引领地，你知道吗？对，当然。在纽约为我姐姐办的，他和他的可爱妻子一起来了，他们走过来打招呼，说他们很喜欢这部电影，我说，你知道，你简直，那是看你在纽约演的那部独角戏，但那是那次旅行，所以当时我大约14岁，我和我妈妈一起去了纽约
to go and see me saw Cabaret and we saw Playbit. He was in where it was a one-man show, and it was at the Walter Kerr Theatre, and I watched it, and I thought, that's it, that's like, this is like a magic trick, you know, that he's doing this play for, however, long 90 minutes, or on just completely on his own. And that cabaret, well, that trip, that was when I thought, right, this is the thing. And I got to tell him, which is so cool. And then when I went back to New York and did the Seagull, when I was about 22, it was at the Walter Curve. Yeah. And there's this amazing line in the Seagull, when Nina, in the second act, she's talking to this writer, that she's a budding actress, and she meets this famous writer, it was played by Tuotá Legifor and London and Peter
去看我看了《歌厅》（Cabaret），我们看了《戏剧》（Playboy）。他在里面演的是一个独角戏，是在沃尔特·科尔剧院（Walter Kerr Theatre）上演的，我看着它，心想，就是那个，这就像是一个魔术，你知道的，他一个人在演这出戏，不管演多久，90分钟，完全靠他自己。还有《歌厅》，那次旅行，那就是我心想，对，就是这个。而且我得以把这件事告诉他，太酷了。后来我回到纽约出演《海鸥》（The Seagull）时，我大约22岁，就在沃尔特·科尔剧院。对。在《海鸥》中有一句精彩的台词，当妮娜在第二幕中，她和这个作家说话，她是一个崭露头角的演员，她遇到了这个著名的作家，伦敦由克里斯托夫·埃克莱斯顿（Christopher Eccleston）扮演，纽约由彼得·萨斯加德（Peter Sarsgaard）扮演。
Sarsgard and New York. And there's this, you know, they have this conversation, and she's just sort of completely overroared by what a genius he is and how he creates. And at the end of the, and she falls in love with them, and at the end of the scene, he walks off stage, and she's on her own, and she sort of looks out over the lake, which is the audience, and she says, I'm dreaming. And I could never do it in London. For some reason, I just couldn't.
你知道，他们有这样一段对话，她完全被他的天才以及他的创作方式所折服。在场景结束时，她爱上了他们，在场景结束时，他走下了舞台，她独自一人，她眺望远处的湖泊——也就是观众席，她说：“我在做梦。”我在伦敦从来做不到这一点。出于某种原因，我就是做不到。
I just always felt like such a knob, and I was just going, I'm dreaming, and then just walk off stage. And the director was always like, come on. And it was the first night of the Walter Kerr, and I looked out and I thought of this sort of 14-year-old me sitting in the stalls, and I said it, and it was the first time I sort of really said it.
我总是觉得自己像个笨蛋，然后我就对自己说，我在做梦，接着就走下台。导演总是在说，来吧。那是沃尔特·克尔剧院的首演夜，我向外看去，想到了那个坐在池座里大约14岁的自己，然后我把它说出来了，那是我第一次真正把话说出口。
You know, it was just, it was just, that's cool. Yeah, it was cool. I love it. Literally just giving goosebumps. Yeah, yeah. Was it, what was the, again, in my crappy research, I stumbled upon something and I can't find it now, but was, what was the show that, where the curtain came down and tell me this is a good theater story? This is my, I was going to say, sure, and this is my good theater story.
你知道，这感觉真的很酷。对，真的很酷。我太喜欢了。简直让人起鸡皮疙瘩。对，对。那是，是什么，再说一次，根据我那稀烂的调查，我偶然发现了一件事，现在找不到了，但是，那是哪个节目，就是幕布降下来的时候——告诉我这是个精彩的剧院故事？这就是我的——我本来想说，当然，这就是我的精彩剧院故事。
I did this one woman show called Girls and Boys in 2018 and I did it at London the Royal Court and then I transferred it to this little theater in New York. And in the show, I played this mother, this woman, and at the start of the show, I'm in front of this curtain, and I am, is a monologue. And then the curtain comes up in a blackout, and I suddenly, there's urine like someone's kitchen living room, and I had these scenes with these invisible children. And the play's very funny and then incredibly dark,
我在2018年演过一个名为《女孩与男孩》的独角戏，先是在伦敦皇家宫廷剧院演的，后来转演到纽约的一家小剧场。在剧里，我扮演一个母亲，一个女人，演出开始时，我站在一块幕布前，这是一个独白。然后幕布在一片黑暗中升起，我突然——就像某人的厨房起居室一样，我跟这些看不见的孩子们有许多对手戏。这部剧非常搞笑，然后变得极其黑暗，
and it's about 90 minutes, where it just, there's blackouts in between scenes, and I just go back and forth and run this curtain. And in New York, there's something, it was the first preview and we got about, it was sort of about 20 minutes for the end of the play and it had gotten to the sort of quite serious part and I did the scene with the kids and then when the blackout was going forward to stand in front of the curtain. And by curtain, you know, we mean like a wooden metal kind of thing that comes down. And something went wrong with the mist timing of the curtain
大约90分钟的时长，场景之间只有暗场，我就是这样来回走动，操控着这块幕布。在纽约有这么个情况，那是第一场预演，距离剧终大概还有20分钟左右，剧情已经发展到了相当严肃的部分，我和孩子们演完了那场戏，接着在暗场转换时，我走到幕布前面。说到幕布，你知道，我们指的是那种会降下来的木质金属结构的东西。结果幕布的时机出了点问题，
and as I kind of came underneath it, it landed sort of on my head. On your head, the whole curtain. Like a pipe. Yeah, well, just sort of struck me and then I shoved away from it and it carried on going down, you know, because it just... Oh, God, because that thing doesn't light. That thing weighs a ton. Yeah, well, it just sort of struck me, and then I shoved away from it, and it carried on going down, you know, because it just took a long time. Because that thing doesn't light, that thing weighs a ton. No, no, no, no.
当我走到它下方时，它直接砸到了我头上。砸到你头上，整块幕布吗？就像一根管子。对，就是，它砸中了我，然后我把它推开，它继续往下落，你知道，因为它就是……哦，天哪，因为那东西不轻。那东西重得要命。对，就是，它砸中了我，然后我把它推开，它继续往下落，你知道，因为它下落需要很长时间。因为那东西不轻，那东西重得要命。不，不，不，不。
I mean, it's like a sort of wooden structure thing, and it comes down quickly, because it was a quick, kind of change into the next scene. So my hair was kind of fucked up, and I sort of, it was unbelievably painful, but then the lights came up, and no one had seen it. So I, so it's not like someone had seen an accident before I could go like, oh, that hurts.. So I just carried on and did that rest and with my hair, and I'm like,
我是说，它就像是一种木质结构的东西，而且它掉下来速度很快，因为那是为了快速切换到下一个场景。所以我的头发被弄得乱七八糟，而且那种痛感简直难以置信，但接着灯光亮起，没有人看到这一幕。所以，所以并不是说在我的反应出来之前别人就看到了事故，觉得“哦，好痛”。所以我只能硬着头皮演完了剩下的部分，顶着乱蓬蓬的头发，我想，
what? And then I, and then I got to the end of it and, you know, finished the play and walked off stage and just burst into tears, and I was hysterical, and I was also convinced that I was going to die, because I thought, you know, head injuries, concussion, blah, I went back up to my room, and I was, you know, it was this tiny, tiny theatre. It didn't have a proper dressing room. It just had like a curtain, sort of one of those partitions and a bit of a curtain. And I was sobbing on the floor and, you know,
什么？然后我，然后我演到了最后，你知道，演完整部剧，走下舞台，当场就哭了出来，我歇斯底里，而且我当时还坚信自己快要死了，因为我想，你知道，头部受伤、脑震荡之类的，我跌跌撞撞地回到化妆间，而那，你知道，那是一个非常非常小的剧院。它甚至没有一个像样的化妆室。只有一个帘子，类似于那种隔断加一截窗帘。我趴在地板上嚎啕大哭，你知道，
various people are trying to calm me down. I was going, oh really? I think it's really bad. And then someone from the theatre comes in and says, I'm so sorry. Um, Bradley Cooper's just sitting just outside. And Bradley was, I had come to the first preview, and was sitting on the sofa outside just waiting.
好几个人试图让我冷静下来。我一边说，噢天哪？我觉得这太严重了。然后剧院里有人走进来对我说，真是不好意思。呃，布莱德利·库珀就坐在外面。布莱德利他来看首演，正坐在外面的沙发上等候。
And this was how many years ago? This was 2018, so this was, yeah. And so, and then I said, oh, bring him in. And he, and he, and he, and he came in and he just got down on the floor and like, looked in my eyes, looked at my pupils, and was like, right, we're going to hospital. So we went and I was like, oh, you did?
这是多少年前的事了？这是2018年的事，所以是，对。然后我说，哦，让他进来。然后他，然后他，然后他，然后他走了进来，直接蹲在我身边，直视着我的双眼，检查了我的瞳孔，然后说，行了，我们得去医院。于是我们去了，我当时想，哦，你真的去了？
And he took you to the hospital? Yeah, I took me to the hospital. See? The first time you met Bradley, he took you to the hospital. No, no, no, we're going to hospital. So we went and I was like, oh, you did it? And he took it to the hospital? Yeah, I took it to the hospital. The first time you met Bradley, he took it to the hospital. No, no, no, no, we had met a bunch of times before. We had come to see me when I did a play with Bill Nye because he's good friends of Bill and we have the same publicist. We'd like bumped into each other at stuff. But yeah, he was good.
他带你去了医院？对，他带我去了医院。你看？你第一次见布莱德利，他就把你带去了医院。不，不，不，我们得去医院。所以我们去了，我当时想，哦，你真的去了？他把你带去了医院？对，他把我带去了医院。你第一次见布莱德利，他就把你带去了医院。不，不，不，我们在那之前已经见过好多次了。我演比尔·奈伊的舞台剧时他就来看过，因为他是比尔的好朋友，而且我们用同一个公关。我们在各种活动上偶遇过。不过对，他人很好。
By the way, he's really good at taking people to the hospital. This is right here. I know, I thought I was bad. He just took, he just took Brooke, you know, to the hospital last week. But I want to say, I don't know about you guys. Kerry, I love when you talk and you're describing anything, you make anything, you can, you can describe anything to me. I just want to call you, can we be friends so that you can just describe? I just want you to describe stuff to me.
顺便说一句，他真的很擅长带别人去医院。这就在这儿呢。我知道，我还以为我很糟糕呢。他上周才刚把布鲁克（你知道的）送去医院。不过我想说，我不知道你们怎么想。凯瑞，我特别喜欢你说话和描述任何事情的方式，你可以把任何事，你什么都能向我描述。我真想打电话给你，我们能做朋友吗，这样你就可以尽情描述了？我只想让你给我描述各种事情。
Have you just said, Matt? No, we met at Bradford's camp. Yeah, we're Bradford's camp. I just love listening to you tell stories. I could just listen to you talk about like you do. Can I just quickly tell you, because I said at the beginning that I, what a massive fan I was of both of you in a rest of development, but Sean.
你刚才是说马特吗？不，我们在布拉德福德营地认识的。对，我们是布拉德福德营地。我就是喜欢听你讲故事。我能一直听你这么说话。我能快速插一句吗，因为我一开始就说过我是你们俩在《发展受阻》里的超级粉丝，但是肖恩——
Uh-oh. Not so much. That's what I was going to say. Sorry, was that not what you were going to say? That's exactly what I was going to say. No, big, big time fan. And when I went to Chile to meet the family... The restaurant? He goes, you got a Chili's once I went to the restaurant. So you didn't do it. I went to the Chile, the country, to go meet the family of the woman I play in my strip in Santiago. And I went there before we started shooting
呃-哦。没那么喜欢。我刚正想这么说呢。抱歉，你刚才不是要这么说吗？这正是我要说的话。不，我是超级、超级粉丝。当我去了智利去见那个家庭……奇利斯餐厅？他说，你去过奇利斯餐厅，我去了那家餐厅。所以你没去成。我去的是智利那个国家，去见我在圣地亚哥拍戏时扮演的那个角色的原型家庭。我在开机前就去了，
what was meant to be a three-day trip and I got COVID on my way out so I was stuck there so I had to stay another week and a half and my kids were in New York with my mum and it was and I was I mean really really horribly horribly upset So I literally couldn't leave my room so I was was in my room in Chile for, and I watched, for the maybe 50th time, Will and Grace, from the first episode of the first season, all the way to the end. No, that was true.
本来打算进行一次三天的旅行，结果在出发路上感染了新冠，所以被困在那里，不得不又多呆了一个半星期，而我的孩子们和我的妈妈在纽约，那感觉，我当时真的是——难过得无以复加。我简直无法离开房间，所以在智利的房间里呆着，把《威尔和格蕾丝》从第一季第一集一直看到大结局，看了大概第50遍。不，这是真的。
And that was what I, yeah, and that was my hat. That's very sweet, Carrie, thank you. That's amazing. I'm guys, what was your favorite episode? Sorry, tell, okay, what is this Will and Grace? Is that a play? Yes, it is. It was a film, Will and Joan. It was one woman show, yeah. One man, tell it. Okay, what is this Will and Grace? Is that a play? Yes, there is. It was a film.
这就是我的，对，那就是我的精神寄托。太甜了，凯瑞，谢谢你。这太棒了。伙计们，你们最喜欢哪一集？抱歉，等等，好吧，这个《威尔和格蕾丝》是什么？是一部戏剧吗？是的，它是。它是一部电影，威尔和琼。是个独角戏，对。独角戏，等等。好吧，这个《威尔和格蕾丝》是什么？是一部戏剧吗？是的，是这样的。它是一部电影。
It was one woman show. Oh. One man, one woman. Yeah. I love. That's sweet, honey. Thank you so much. No, really, I love it so much.
是个独角戏。哦。独角戏，一个人演的。对。我喜欢。太贴心了，亲爱的。非常感谢。不，真的，我太喜欢了。
I think it's incredible. It really is. It's chasing. No, I'm serious. I was a big dork fan of yours before I met you. But Jason, you came to like, two or three shows too. Yeah. Then you came to the last, the very, very last show.
我觉得这太不可思议了。真的。太迷人了。不，我是认真的。在你认识你之前，我就是你的超级书呆子粉丝。不过杰森，你也去看了两三场演出吧。对。然后你去了最后一场，最、最、最末的一场。
Oh. You went to the last one. Yeah, Jay was at the very last show. We'll be right back. Smartless fans, listen up. Have you heard you can listen to episodes of this very show, Add Free, and One Week Early on Amazon Music with your Prime Membership? That's right.
哦。你去了最后一场。对，杰伊去了最后一场。我们马上回来。《发展受阻》的粉丝们，注意啦。你们听说过可以用Prime会员在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上免广告、提前一周收听本节目吗？没错。
All your favorite smartness episodes can be heard on Amazon Music ad-free and you'll always be the first one to catch our new episode so you can brag to your friends. Now listen, some people might be bragging, some people might be criticizing. They might say, oh boy, listen, I heard the latest smartness because I got this ad-free Amazon Music and you'd save yourself the problem.
你所有最喜欢的《发展受阻》单集都可以在亚马逊音乐上免广告收听，而且你永远是第一批听到我们新节目的人，这样你就可以在朋友面前炫耀了。现在听着，有些人可能在炫耀，有些人可能在批评。他们可能会说，哦天哪，听着，我听到了最新的《发展受阻》，因为我有这个免广告的亚马逊音乐，这样你就省去了很多麻烦。
You don't need to listen. So see you can either be ahead with positive or negative. The choice is yours. That's all we're trying to do is load you up with choice, you know, but that's not all. You can listen to your other favorite shows, like I don't know, bad dates
你不需要去听。所以你可以选择带着积极或消极的态度领先一步。选择权在你手里。我们想做的就是为你提供各种选择，你知道，但这还不是全部。你还可以收听其他你最喜欢的节目，比如，我不知道，《糟糕的约会》
and just Jack and Will, early and ad free too. They also have favorites like the daily part might take and up first all without ads. You know what this means uninterrupted listening so no more cliffhangers. Amazon Music offers the most ad free top podcasts so we know they definitely have something for you and it's already included in your prime membership. To listen now, all you need to do is go to Amazon.com slash smart list. That's Amazon.com slash smart list or download the Amazon music app. It's just that easy. Happy holidays, everyone. And my gift for you? It's the gift of comedy, two comedies, in fact.
以及《杰克与威尔》，同样可以提前且免广告收听。他们还有诸如《每日播客》、《The Take》和《Up First》等热门节目，全部都没有广告。你知道这意味着什么吗？不间断收听，再也没有悬念了。亚马逊音乐提供了最多免广告的顶级播客，所以我们知道这里面绝对有适合你的内容，而且它已经包含在你的Prime会员资格中了。想要立刻收听，你只需访问 Amazon.com 斜杠 smartlist。也就是 Amazon.com 斜杠 smartlist，或者下载亚马逊音乐应用程序。就是这么简单。祝大家节日快乐。我送给你们的礼物是什么？是喜剧的礼物，事实上是两部喜剧。
The comedies of two amazing Johns. John Lerichette in the new season of Nightcourt, and John Crier in his new comedy extended family. That's right. Court is back in session, Tuesdays on NBC, with America's number one comedy, Nightcourt, starring the iconic John Lerichette in the role that won him so many awards it's embarrassing. And after that, it's another TV legend, John Cryer.
两位了不起的约翰的喜剧。约翰·拉罗奎特（John Larroquette）主演的新一季《夜间法庭》（Nightcourt），以及约翰·克莱尔（John Cryer）主演的新喜剧《实习老爸》（Extended Family）。没错。法庭再度开庭，每周二在NBC播出，这是全美排名第一的喜剧《夜间法庭》，由标志性的约翰·拉罗奎特主演，这个角色为他赢得了无数奖项，多到让人都不好意思了。在那之后，是另一位电视传奇人物约翰·克莱尔。
In a comedy about life and family after divorce, extended family, also starring the hilarious, Donald, Faesonzon and Abigail Spencer. It's the gift of comedy people to comedies starring two Johns, John Lericette and John Cryer, Nightcourt, and extended family. Two gifts you will surely love this season, unless you are a miserable Scrooge person. Tuesdays on NBC starting January 2nd. starting January 2nd. Thank you to Audible for their support. A deep and sincere thanks. Because Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app.
这是一部关于离婚后生活与家庭的喜剧——《实习老爸》，同时主演的还有搞笑的唐纳德·法森和阿比盖尔·斯宾塞。把喜剧作为礼物送给大家吧，两部由两位约翰主演的喜剧：约翰·拉罗奎特和约翰·克莱尔的《夜间法庭》与《实习老爸》。这个季节你一定会爱上的两份礼物，除非你是个悲惨的吝啬鬼。每周二在NBC开播，1月2日开始。从1月2日开始。感谢Audible对我们的支持。致以最深切、最真诚的感谢。因为Audible让你在一个应用程序中就能尽情享受所有音频娱乐。
You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. There's an incredible selection of audio books across every genre from best sellers, new releases, celebrity memoirs, mysteries, thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, more. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog of thousands of titles. Now, I just recently took a look at Liz Cheney's, I believe it's called, Oath in Honor. I mean, I'm a political junkie. I like to hear about it from all sides. So she's got a bunch of really interesting stuff
你总能找到你最爱的好书，或者发现一些全新的内容。这里有跨越各个流派的不可思议的有声书选择，从畅销书、新书发布、名人回忆录、悬疑、惊悚到励志、健康、商业等等。作为Audible会员，你可以从数千部作品的整个目录中每个月挑选一本自己永久保留。现在，我最近刚刚看了一下莉兹·切尼的——我相信它叫《荣誉誓言》。我的意思是一个政治迷。我喜欢听取各个方面的声音。所以她在她的书里写了很多非常有趣的内容，
in her book about all of the Misha Goss and it's compelling. It's whatever the digital equivalent of a page turner is, it's that. I mean, it's clickable, maybe something? I don't know. We'll get back to that. I mean, it's clickable. Maybe something. I don't know. We'll get back to that. But new members can try audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or tech smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless or tech smartless to 500-500 to try audible free for 30 days. Be sure to visit our URL so they know we sent you audible.com slash smartless.
关于所有的宫廷秘史（Misha Goss），非常引人入胜。这就是数字时代的“翻页狂魔”，就是那种感觉。我的意思是可以点击，也许类似的东西？我不知道。我们待会儿再讨论这个。我的意思是可以点击。也许类似的东西。我不知道。我们待会儿再讨论。不过新成员可以免费体验Audible 30天。访问 audible.com 斜杠 smartlist，或者发送短信 smartlist 到 500 500。也就是 audible.com 斜杠 smartlist，或者发送短信 smartlist 到 500-500 来免费体验 Audible 30天。一定要访问我们的网址，让他们知道是我们介绍你来的：audible.com 斜杠 smartlist。
And now back to the show. Now I'm imagining, Carrie, that with your, you're, you're, you have a very exciting life with all the fancy places you get to go for your work, but all the fancy places you get to go for Marcus' work too. What is the, have you, did you meet the most impressive person in your work or when you were with him for his work? Like, who got you most starcer? Cause like actors always geek out around musicians
现在让我们回到节目中。我现在在想，凯瑞，你的生活非常激动人心，因为你的工作可以去各种高档的地方，不过你也能因为马库斯的工作去各种高档的地方。在你的工作中，或者当你在陪他工作时，你遇到过最让人印象深刻的人吗？比如，谁最让你觉得像个小粉丝一样激动？因为演员在音乐家面前总是像个极客，
and vice versa for athletes. Who's been the coolest person you've met with Marcus? Springsteen was the coolest. Yeah, that's good. By a long way. I mean, not by a long way, I've met lovely people. But Springsteen made me go, I just, and I don't think I could,
运动员也是如此。和马库斯在一起时，你见过的最酷的人是谁？斯普林斯廷（Springsteen）是最酷的。对，这很棒。遥遥领先。我的意思是，倒也不是遥遥领先，我遇到过很多可爱的人。但斯普林斯廷让我觉得，我简直，而且我觉得我当时，
I couldn't really function. I just sort of, you know, he just ruins me. Yeah, but going back to like the thing I asked you before, were you a fan of Marcus's music or that style or that genre, or did he open you up to be like, like, what did you listen to before and what was it the same then and now? No, I was like S-club seven, Backstreet Boys, West Life. Yeah. There was a brand of music that they used to call, I went to boarding Club 7, Backstreet Boys, West Life. There was a brand of music that they used to call,
我简直无法正常运转了。我差不多就是，你知道的，他直接把我击溃了。对，但回到我之前问你的问题，你以前是马库斯的音乐、那种风格或流派的粉丝吗？还是说他启发了你？你以前听什么，那时候和现在是一样的吗？不，我喜欢S-Club 7、后街男孩（Backstreet Boys）、西城男孩（Westlife）。对。有一种音乐流派，他们以前管那叫——我上寄宿学校时，Club 7、后街男孩、西城男孩。有一种音乐流派，他们以前管那叫——
I went to boarding school and I used to, the girls at school used to, my genre was Carrie Trash, because I just listened to like... Carrie Trash. Yeah, Carrie Trash. Wait, Backstreet Boys, was that Justin Timberlake or was that in sync?
我上寄宿学校时，学校里的女孩们经常——我的曲风叫“凯瑞垃圾”（Carrie Trash），因为我听的都是……凯瑞垃圾。对，凯瑞垃圾。等等，后街男孩，那是贾斯汀·汀布莱克（Justin Timberlake）还是超级男孩（In Sync）？
That was in sync. That was very good. Backstreet Boys was, yeah, sort of... But when you worked, didn't you work with Justin and... In Inside Leon Davis, yeah. Where I worked with Marcus, and that was the thing it was, yeah, sort of. But when you worked, didn't you work with Justin and, uh, Luenal? In Inside Lu and Davis, yeah. Where I worked with Marcus, and that was the thing I was going to say that if we had not met as adults in Nashville, which is how we did end up meeting, we would have met on that job because we both got hired, uh-huh, independent of one another to do it. Because he did the music and I did the acting thing.
那是超级男孩。那真的很棒。后街男孩是，对，某种……不过当你工作的时候，你不是跟贾斯汀合作过吗，还有……在《醉乡民谣》（Inside Llewyn Davis）里，对。我在那里和马库斯合作过，那就是我要说的，如果我们不是作为成年人在纳什维尔相遇——我们确实是在那相遇的——我们也会在那项工作里相遇的，因为我们俩都是各自独立被雇佣去参与的。因为他做音乐，我演戏。
Got you. So you didn't really listen to Mumford and Sons before you? Wow. No, but I thought, so I went to a Laura Marling gig when I was like 19, a sort of, you know, church in London and Mumford and Sons with a support act. There was one of their first ever gigs and I, and when he came out, I remember thinking, oh, God, I knew a guy called Mumford. I went to campus, you know, but he was so tall and when I met him, he was tiny and then he started singing
原来如此。所以你以前其实并不听孟福德与之子（Mumford and Sons）的歌？哇。没有，不过我想，我19岁时去听过劳拉·马林（Laura Marling）的演出，在伦敦的一个教堂里，孟福德与之子是暖场嘉宾。那是他们最早的演出之一，当他走出来时，我记得自己当时想，天哪，我认识一个叫孟福德的家伙。我去过校园，你知道的，但他个子好高，当我见到他时，他却很小一只，然后他开始唱歌，
and I said to my best friend, Moth, next to me, I went, oh God, Moth is so shouty. Because it was very shouty back then and I think he's less shouty. Oh my God. It was very shouty. I don't know how funny. I like it, you're like, in my defense, it was very shouty.
我对身边的挚友莫斯（Moth）说，天哪，莫斯，他喊得好大声。因为那时候的歌声非常具有嘶吼感，我觉得他现在没那么大声了。天哪。喊得太厉害了。我不知道有多搞笑。我喜欢，你会说，为了辩护一下，当时确实喊得很厉害。
Kerry, be honest, how many ace of Base concerts have you been to? I never watched the concert, but I would have died too. Okay, I would have gone with you. Yeah. Yeah. What can you tell us about, because you know, I would imagine you've had some, some pretty low hanging fruit thrown your way because you're so successful like, hey, why don't you be the star of this crappy film or let's give you all the money to do this.
凯瑞，说实话，你去过多少次荒凉乐队（Ace of Base）的演唱会？我从没看过他们的演唱会，但我也会死去的。好吧，我会陪你去的。对。对。关于这一点，你能跟我们分享点什么吗？因为我觉得，你这么成功，肯定遇到过不少轻而易举、唾手可得的机会，比如，“嘿，你要不要来当这部烂片的明星”或者“我们给你一大笔钱来做这个”。
You always pick these incredibly tasteful projects, whether it be the premise of it or the people that are involved with it. Tell us a little bit about what's the most attractive thing about a project for you. Is it the characters, is it the script, is it the director, is it the, how do you go about picking all these great things and never picking any stinkers? Looks like a lot of discipline. I've been really lucky. I think I also, yeah, I think largely big time
但你总是能挑到这些极其有品味的项目，无论是它的前提还是参与的人员。跟我们聊聊，对你来说，一个项目中最具吸引力的东西是什么？是角色、剧本、导演，还是其他什么？你是如何挑选到所有这些好东西、而从不踩雷的？看起来需要极大的自律。我真的非常幸运。我想我也，对，我觉得很大程度上很大程度上。
director definitely, but within that just, well, you know, my agent tour, who's been my agent for almost 20 years, she's like wonderful, and she sort of family. And when an education happens and suddenly I was getting off for jobs a bit more, you know, she said, look, you're in this really rare part of an actor's career where you can, you don't have to say yes to everything. And that's a real privilege. And whilst you're in that place, you really shouldn't take a part unless you can't bear the idea of someone else playing it. And you've got this capital and it's yours. Yeah. And if you can imagine someone else, one of you can tell her is playing the part and thinking like, well, that's okay. You know, going to sit in the cinema with someone else
导演当然是，但在那其中，你知道的，我的经纪人，她做我的经纪人快20年了，她非常好，就像家人一样。当事业有起色，我突然接到更多工作邀请时，你知道，她说，听着，你正处于演员生涯中一个非常罕见的阶段，你可以，你不需要对每件事都说“好”。这真的是一种特权。当你在那个位置时，除非你无法忍受别人去演这个角色，否则你真的不应该接下它。你拥有这种资本，而且它是属于你的。是的。如果你能想象别人，你们中的一个人可以告诉她是在演这个角色，然后想，嗯，那也行。你知道，坐在电影院里看别人演
and being all right with it, then she was like, then don't do it. Wow. But do you, when you look at, when you look at stuff, do you think like, oh, this is gonna work? Or do you think, no, I have to do this because it really speaks to me
而且觉得也无所谓，那她说，那就别演。哇。但是你，当你看着，当你看着剧本时，你会想，哦，这会成功吗？还是你会想，不，我必须得演，因为这真的很触动我
and this is something where I can really, I feel like I can, there's something about it that I feel like I can, there's something about it that I feel like I can express myself in a really way or whatever, or do you think about the success of it? Like, oh, this will be a cool thing and people will think this is cool. Oh God, no, no, no.
而且这是我真正能，我觉得我能，有那么一点让我觉得我可以，有那么一点让我觉得我能以一种真正的方式表达自己，或者别的什么，还是你会去想它的成功与否？比如，哦，这会是个很酷的东西，人们会觉得这很酷。哦，天哪，不，不，不。
No, I mean, I generally have a bit of a kind of, if it doesn't scare me, it's not enormously attractive, which is, you know, the kind of masochistic. I mean, girls and boys, when I did that, the monologue, I couldn't get through the first page of a dress rehearsal until the first preview. I mean, I literally couldn't get on stage. Oh, no. Like, there was something about talking, well, but you know what else it was? It was that the first sort of 45 minutes of the play was funny, and that scared the shit out of me. Like, when I read it, it made me laugh. And the idea of having failed
不，我是说，我通常有一种，如果它不吓到我，它就没有那么大吸引力，你知道，这就是那种自虐倾向。我是说，《女孩与男孩》，当我演那个的时候，从彩排到第一场预演，我连第一页都读不完。我是说，我简直无法上台。哦，不。就好像，谈论，好吧，但你知道还有什么吗？那就是这出戏的前45分钟是搞笑的，这把我吓死了。当我读剧本时，它逗笑了我。而一想到会失败
by not making the audience laugh just felt, I mean, I could get out there and cry for England, but I think comedy is so hard. And the idea of going out and bombing in that way, and people not laughing. And also the play required that. It needed the first half to be funny, because the second half was just devastating. So I couldn't just make it.
因为没能逗笑观众而失败，那种感觉，我是说，我可以为了国家去哭，但我认为喜剧太难了。那种走上台却彻底砸了场子、人们不笑的感觉。而且这出戏也需要这样。它需要上半场是搞笑的，因为下半场简直是毁灭性的。所以我不能只是把它……
It would just be misery porn if it was just, I couldn't do that. And that's misery porn. So I, you must feel more confident about your ability to be comedic inside your skill set and your taste. In other words, like you're not trying to be funny doing broad stuff. You're being successfully funny playing characters that are eccentric or broken or flawed or like promising young woman.
如果只是那样，那就纯粹是苦难色情片了，我做不到。那是苦难色情片。所以，对于自己在喜剧方面的能力，在你的技能范围和审美之内，你肯定更有自信了。换句话说，你不是在强行搞笑。你通过扮演那些古怪、破碎、有缺陷的角色，或者像《前程似锦的女孩》那样的角色，成功地做到了搞笑。
That's a dark comedy that you know, it just seemed you were very confident with your dark comedic sensibility. I think with the theatre thing, it was that like, I just needed to figure out who I was talking to. You know, there was some part of me that thought, what is this, you know, is this a convention for grief or what, you know, I just couldn't figure out who the audience was because I didn't have that other actor on stage with me to tell the, you know, to communicate with, so I was like, the biggest block was like, who are these people that I'm telling
那是一部黑色喜剧，你知道，看起来你对自己的黑色喜剧触觉非常自信。我觉得对于戏剧来说，就是我只需要弄清楚我在跟谁说话。你知道，我心里的一部分在想，这是什么，你知道，这是个悼念会还是什么，你知道，我就是弄不清观众是谁，因为台下没有另一个演员和我搭戏来传递，你知道，去交流，所以我就想，最大的障碍就像是，这群人到底是谁，我在向他们讲述
this thing to? And then when I kind of figured that out and you know what else? I took my shoes off. And suddenly when I was barefoot, I could do it. It was the weirdest thing. Really? Really relaxing. Yeah, I just, the whole, I thought it was just grounded and I was like, oh, okay.
这些事情？然后当我大概弄明白了，你知道还有什么吗？我脱掉了鞋子。突然间，当我赤脚的时候，我就能演了。这真是最奇怪的事情。真的吗？真的很放松。是的，我只是，整个人，我觉得自己脚踏实地了，然后我就想，哦，好吧。
So now it makes, and then it became my favorite thing I've ever done on stage, and I absolutely loved it. And I sort of mourned it for a long time. I'm like, this is... I warned you, I warned you blown away, but the first play you did, and then subsequently everything else, weren't you blown away by the endurance that you have to figure out in order to do, especially a one woman show, where it's just you
所以现在它变得，然后它成了我在舞台上做过的最喜欢的作品，我太爱它了。我甚至为此伤心了很久。我想，这……我警告过你，我警告过你，你被震撼到了，但你演的第一部戏，以及后来的所有作品，难道你没有被那种为了坚持下去而必须付出的耐力所震撼吗，特别是单人秀，台上只有你
and the energy that you have to find every single day of your life to do that at that time. It's mad, it's mad. And it just gets impossible with kids because you will do it. So you find yourself barefooting pregnant? Yeah. Well, I was pregnant on Broadway when I did skylight with Bill. And almost seven months pregnant by the time I finished it. And I've never been so.
还有你每天都要调动精力去完成这些。这太疯狂了，太疯狂了。有了孩子之后这根本不可能，因为你还是得做。所以你会发现自己赤脚怀着孕？是的。我在百老汇和比尔一起演《天窗》时就怀着孕。演完的时候已经怀孕快七个月了。我从来没有这么……
And it was so funny because the baby would sort of respond to their flaws. I thought this was really setting us up for a problem. But yeah. You know, you speak of what for you now? Now that you've, I mean, you've got three kids, you've got, as Jason said at the start, you've got all this, you know, all the acclaim and in respect that you could, you could ever want doing what we do. What for you is, what does success mean to you now? Like what is, what would you go like at the end of a day or a week or a month, you say, like, yeah, you feel like, great, because you've had all this stuff and you've had all the thing. Like what, what do you look for now? What are the things that are what are the
太搞笑了，因为宝宝似乎会对台词做出反应。我想这真是给我们出了个大难题。不过是的。你知道，你现在追求什么？既然你，我是说，你有了三个孩子，正如杰森在一开始说的，你拥有了，你知道，从事我们这一行所能期望的一切赞誉和尊重。对你来说，什么是，现在成功对你意味着什么？比如你会觉得，在一天、一周或一个月结束时，你会说，是的，你觉得，太棒了，因为你经历了这一切，拥有了这一切。比如现在，你在寻找什么？有哪些是
mountains that you want to climb sort of personally as a person? I don't know. I mean, I feel increasingly just sort of unbelievably lucky. We've got three healthy kids and we both get to do jobs that we really love, you know. And that's so that I think that gives you a lot, you know, that makes... that takes away a lot of kind of regular life stress, you know, so many people have to work and jobs they hate and, you know, and so many people, you know, you just see more and more of your friends and people around you, you know, sort of hearing stories of people's
作为一个人，你个人想要攀登的高峰？我不知道。我是说，我越来越觉得自己有一种难以置信的幸运。我们有三个健康的宝贝，我们俩都能从事我们真正热爱的工作，你知道。这太好了，所以我觉得这给了你很多，你知道，这消除了……这消除了很多日常生活中的压力，你知道，那么多人都不得不做他们讨厌的工作，你知道，而且有那么多人，你知道，你越来越多地看到你的朋友和周围的人，你知道，听到关于人们
health issues or kids that have not, you know, and it's just, God, she's think constantly, like, wow, we've managed to really swerve that stuff so far, touch with all that, like, you know, thank you, Lord, but it just feels like that is, you know, happy, you know, healthy home life and also like the ability to work. And, you know, whatever scale that is, whether it's giant films or whether it's theatre or whether it's just, you know, but to be able to work and actually go and earn money doing something that you really, really love,
健康问题或孩子有什么状况的故事，然后就会想，天哪，你会经常想，哇，到目前为止我们真的设法避开了那些事，谢天谢地，你知道，感谢上帝，但感觉那就是，你知道，幸福的、你知道，健康的家庭生活，还有工作的能力。而且，你知道，无论那是怎样的规模，无论是巨制电影，还是戏剧，或者是，你知道，但能够工作并且真正去靠做一件你非常非常热爱的事情来赚钱，
it doesn't really need to be any kind of trajectory for me. It's just, you know, that hopefully next year, I'll get to make another film at some point that's good with all of us. Thank you, chances are good. Chances are pretty good on that. Yeah, these are the best. Well, how had you worked with it with a director
对我来说真的不需要有什么特定的发展轨迹。就是，你知道，希望明年，我能在某个时候拍另一部我们大家一起演的好电影。希望很大。这方面的机会挺大的。对，这些是最好的。那么，你曾和一位
that was also acting in the scene with you before Lysro? How did you enjoy that or not? And what was Bradley's style with that? Would he direct you during a take? Or would he wait until the end of it and be a director as opposed to giving you direction in character in very soon?
在片场也和你演对手戏的导演合作过吗，在《音乐大师》之前？你喜欢还是不喜欢那种合作？布莱德利的风格是怎样的？他会在拍摄过程中指导你吗？还是说他会等到一条拍完，作为一个导演，而不是在戏里直接给你指导？
I loved it. I loved it. I loved it. Um, he would do it. Well, he wouldn't do it like, well, he was basically Lenny from the minute he walked on set. So, you know, he was in his, you know, whole thing dialogue, his dialect. He was chain smoking by the camera directing everyone.
我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。嗯，他会这样做。好吧，他不会像……嗯，他从走进片场的那一分钟起就是伦尼了。所以，你知道，他一直处于那种状态，台词，他的方言。他一边抽着连环烟，一边在摄像机旁指挥着所有人。
Well, just, just such, my sister knows, um, he plays Leonard Bernstein. Bernstein? Bernstein people. Bernstein. Bernstein. Yeah, I can't get any wrong, the Bradley was so annoyed with me. And you play Leonard's wife, yeah. Yeah, I play his wife.
好吧，就像，就像，我妹妹认识，嗯，他扮演伦纳德·伯恩斯坦。伯恩斯坦？伯恩斯坦的人。伯恩斯坦。伯恩斯坦。是的，我可不能弄错，布莱德利会生我的气的。而你扮演伦纳德的妻子，对吧。对，我扮演他的妻子。
Yeah, I loved it. It was, you know, because he would direct me not through, sort of, giving me verbal directions as in Do This Do That. He would, he would sort of mold the scene or play his role in a way that would affect mine, you know. So it would be more in the way that he would play Lenny that would affect mine, Felicia, then actually sort of, but he also gave me like note notes, but a lot of it was sort of, I'd find us taking it in a certain direction because he had kind of pushed it that way through playing his role the way it was. Did any part of that seem interesting or attractive to you to do one day?
对，我太喜欢了。你知道，因为他指导我不是通过那种给我口头指示，比如“这样做那样做”。他会，他会塑造那个场景，或者以一种会影响我的方式来扮演他的角色，你知道。所以比起真正的那种，更多的是通过他扮演伦尼的方式来影响我——菲利西亚，当然他也确实给了我一些具体的笔记，但很大程度上是，我发现我们会把表演引向某个特定的方向，因为他通过那样诠释自己的角色，把局势推向了那个方向。这其中有任何一部分让你觉得有趣或者吸引人，让你也想有一天去尝试吗？
Big no. No. No. No. Really. Tell us, come figure out how we do it. I can't figure out how anyone does it. I think it's, I mean, I don't know how you do it. It's just, yeah, I can't.
绝对不。不。不。不。真的吗？告诉我们，快来想想我们是怎么做到的。我无法想象任何人是怎么做到的。我觉得这，我是说，我不知道你是怎么做到的。就是，是的，我做不到。
But you've been on so many great sets with so many incredible directors. Like, I mean, I just, I don't know if I'd be able to say a word if I was performing for the Cohen brothers, saying that them alone would be, or Steve McQueen, or, I mean, these directors, you could cherry pick from so many great ones and probably do an incredible job as a director if you wanted to. I just don't, yeah, I don't have the heart for it. I think you have to love it so much, because it's such an incredible amount of work. I think you have to love it so much, because it's such an incredible amount of work.
但你曾参与过那么多优秀的片场，与那么多不可思议的导演合作过。比如，我是说，我不知道如果我是为科恩兄弟表演，我是否还能说出话来，仅仅是想到这一点，或者史蒂夫·麦奎因，或者，我是说，这些导演，你可以从这么多伟大的导演中挑选，如果你想的话，你大概也能成为一个出色的导演。我只是觉得，是的，我没有那个魄力。我觉得你必须非常热爱它，因为那是极其巨大的工作量。我觉得你必须非常热爱它，因为那是极其巨大的工作量。
I think you have to absolutely love it to be able to do it. And I just don't have it. I just feel like such a jobbing actor. I just want to be surprised by something. Well, it's not the acting. So why are you here? Why are you here doing press-well?
你必须绝对热爱它才能做到这一点。而我没有那种热情。我只觉得自己是个普普通通的职业演员。我只想对某些事物感到惊喜。好吧，那不是演戏。那你为什么在这？你为什么在这做宣传采访？
Yeah, well, we've got you. Yeah. Why are we've got you? What are you going to do? Do you have time to go hang out while you're in LA or do fun things or is it all worth it? Oh, this is a trap. Carry, tell me.
是的，好吧，因为我们抓到你了。是的。为什么我们抓到你了？你打算做什么？你在洛杉矶的时候有时间去闲逛或者做有趣的事吗，还是这一切都安排得满满的？哦，这是个陷阱。凯瑞，告诉我。
You're busy. So you're busy, you're busy. I'm busy. I'm pretty for lunch. I'm going to go to a private, like an early breakfast tomorrow. No, no, no. No, no, no, no. It's actually, it's quite nice.
你很忙。所以你很忙，你很忙。我很忙。我差不多要吃午饭了。我明天要参加一个私人聚会，比如一个早茶。不，不，不。不，不，不，不。实际上，这挺不错的。
Like, today I'm having lunch with, so I'm doing this thing tonight. Can I plug my charity? Yes, please. Oh, yes. All simers or... No, this is a war-kid. War-kid. War-kid. So this is not my... I didn't found this charity, but I'm an ambassador for this charity. So tonight, there's a dinner for a variety dinner
比如，今天我要和……所以我今晚要参加一个活动。我能为我的慈善机构打个广告吗？好的，请便。哦，太好了。是阿尔茨海默症还是……不，这是“童军”（Waterchild）。“童军”。“童军”。所以这不是我的……我没有创立这个慈善机构，但我是这个慈善机构的大使。所以今晚，有一个综合晚宴
and they're giving people prizes for whatever. So I have to make a speech, but we get $10,000 for Waterchild. And Waterchild UK is a charity that I've worked with for about 10 years that looks after children in conflict zones. So today I'm having lunch with Rob Williams, who's flown in for a He's the CEO of the charity, and he is my absolute hero. And has been, you know, an NGO worker for 30 years and runs this organisation and travels all over the world doing, you know, an NGO worker for 30 years and runs this organization and travels all over
他们会给各种奖项颁奖。所以我必须做个演讲，但我们可以为“童军”筹集1万美元。“童军”英国分会是我合作了大约10年的一个慈善机构，它照顾冲突地区的儿童。所以今天我要和罗布·威廉姆斯共进午餐，他特地飞来参加……他是该慈善机构的首席执行官，他绝对是我的偶像。并且一直是，你知道的，一名30年的非政府组织工作者，经营着这个组织，并前往世界各地做着，你知道的，一名30年的非政府组织工作者，经营着这个组织，并前往世界各地
the world doing, you know, amazing work. I mean, recently got back from Afghanistan where he was literally negotiating with the Taliban about women being able to go to work for, for watch out. So, like, that has to be negotiated. It's astonishing. Yeah, it's wild. But they, you know, obviously do incredible work and never more needed than now. That's unbelievable. And there's some unbelievable, there are people out there doing stuff like that. First of all, you're involved with it is amazing. And there are people out there doing important stuff. And obviously everybody's got their own thing.
做着，你知道，了不起的工作。我是说，他最近刚从阿富汗回来，在那里他 literalmente（字面意思： literalmente 略）在与塔利班谈判，关于女性是否能够去工作，为了“童军”。所以，这都需要去谈判。这太惊人了。是的，太疯狂了。但他们，你知道的，显然在做着不可思议的工作，而且现在比以往任何时候都更需要他们。这太难以置信了。而且有非常了不起的，有这样的人在做那种事。首先，你能参与其中就太棒了。而且外面有人在做重要的事情。显然每个人都有自己的事。
Sean was saying the other day, he couldn't find parking on Crescent next to the Beverly Hills Hotel. And so we had to end up had to use the valet. But everybody's got their things. That's how, yeah., yeah, they put up their website Sean You can donate to yeah, Sean Hayes You can click on and then carry hang on we'll get to you So but no, but it carry is there is there some sort of a website a website or is it somebody wants to check out what's going on? WWW.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W. art therapy and fucking great. It's linked to help them with the covers.
肖恩前几天说，他在比弗利山庄酒店旁边的弯月街（Crescent）找不到停车位。所以我们最后不得不叫代客泊车。但每个人都有自己的事。就是这样，是的，他们把网站挂出来了，肖恩，你可以捐款，是的，肖恩·海斯，你可以点击，然后凯瑞，等一下，我们会轮到你的。所以，不，但是凯瑞，有没有某种网站，一个网站，或者如果有人想了解进展情况？WWW点……是关于艺术疗法的，非常棒。它与帮助他们……有关。
It's really cool. Yeah, it's amazing, amazing work. Yeah. What do you guys do that that dumbs it down after you're finished doing your your incredible smart work? Oh, um, lots of television. Lots of telling. Lots of telling.
这真的很酷。是的，这是了不起的、了不起的工作。是的。当你们做完那些不可思议的、聪明的工作后，你们会做些什么来放松大脑？哦，嗯，看很多电视。看很多电视。看很多电视。
Now this is reality television or is it like, you know, I do a bit of reality television, but he is passionate about below deck, which is- Oh, wow. Which I can't go there, but he's that good. I go there, and then I feel like I need a shower afterwards. Who, who deck? Oh, below deck.
这档是真人秀电视节目吗，还是类似于，你知道的，我偶尔看点真人秀，但他对《Below Deck》（下铺船长）情有独钟——哦，哇。我无法理解，但他就是那么喜欢。我去看一眼，然后觉得自己看完后需要洗个澡。谁？哪部船长？哦，《Below Deck》。
Below deck. Oh, below deck. Oh, below deck. Oh, sorry, below deck. Below deck. Sometimes Scott and I play that. Got it. And what is you guys just, you know, change who plays deck?
《Below Deck》。哦，《Below Deck》。哦，《Below Deck》。哦，抱歉，《Below Deck》。《Below Deck》。有时我和斯科特会玩那个。明白了。你们俩就是，你知道的，轮流扮演船长？
Yeah, that's it. Yeah. So you'll watch some TV, we will. What's your first TV? Yeah. Are you guys foodies? Do you like restaurants? Do you go over to friends houses?
对，就是这样。是的。所以你们会看点电视，我们会看的。你们最常看什么电视？是的。你们是美食爱好者吗？喜欢去餐馆吗？还是去朋友家里？
We do friends houses. We do, we live, you know, we do quite, not mega outdoorsy, but quite outdoorsy. Wait, wouldn't I be like camping? You guys go camping? No, he goes camping with the kiddles. I draw the line at camping. What does the camping look like? Is there a fancy van that they sleep in or they pitch a tent? It does. He's a real man. We're near where you live, we're like a light to dream.
我们去朋友家。我们，我们过着，你知道的，不算超级户外，但也算挺户外的。等等，难道不是像露营那样？你们去露营吗？不，他和孩子们去露营。我绝对不露营。那露营是什么样的？他们睡在豪华房车里还是搭帐篷？确实。他是个真正的男子汉。我们离你住的地方不远，我们就像在一个美梦里。
Like outside our house. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of my head. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back. I'll tell you in the back. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back. I'll tell you in the two. Kerry, we are over time. We owe you five minutes of dollars. That's true. Thanks for saying yes to doing this. Oh my God. That's a having me open. That's so cool. Best of luck with all of the chat and giggle sessions you're going to have for Maestro.
就像在我们房子外面。我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里。我会在脑海里。我会在脑海里……我会在脑海里。我会在脑海里。凯瑞，我们超时了。我们欠你五分钟。确实。谢谢你答应来做这个节目。哦，天哪。谢谢你们邀请我。太棒了。祝你为《音乐大师》进行的所有聊天和访谈活动一切顺利。
It's incredible. Incredible. And worth your talking about it. It's incredible. There's a scene again, before we let you go, there's a scene when you're folding the tissue paper that for me is just like an absolute, just brought me to my knees. I can't believe it. Yeah, so good.
这太不可思议了。不可思议。非常值得你去谈论它。这太不可思议了。还有一个场景，在我们放你走之前，有一个场景是你折叠薄绢纸的镜头，对我来说简直是绝杀，直接让我惊叹到跪下了。我简直不敢相信。是的，太棒了。
So everybody go see Meister. And also one more time with the web address for the charity please. Oh, www.wchild.co.uk. They need you right now. Yeah, they need you right now. Sean, the one for the parking spots. So that's just Sean Hayes, the up and down. That's just a hot track.
所以大家都去看看《音乐大师》吧。还有，请再报一次慈善机构的网址。哦，www.wchild.co.uk。他们现在需要你。是的，他们现在需要你。肖恩，那个停车位的网址。那就直接找肖恩·海斯，上下滚动。那只是个热门链接。
That's a hot track. Sean, go one really quick with your mobile number. Yeah, so it's 310. OK. Carrie, have a great day. Thank you. Say hi to Marcus. Bye great day. Thank you. Say hi to Marcus.
那是热门链接。肖恩，快报一下你的手机号码。好的，是310。好了，凯瑞，祝你有美好的一天。谢谢。代我向马库斯问好。美好的一天。谢谢。代我向马库斯问好。
Bye, carry. Thank you. I'll stick to you for the reshoots. You know, we're going to do some reshoots on this. Yeah. We'll check your bill. All right. We'll see you now.
再见，凯瑞。谢谢。我会盯着你拍补拍镜头的。你知道的，我们要为这个拍一些补拍镜头。对。我们会查账单的。好了。我们回头见。
What's the slammichut? Oh, do I? Yeah. Bye. Jason, what a guest. Yeah. You did it. What a guest you had.
三明治吃完了吗？哦，吃完了吗？再见。杰森，真是个绝佳的嘉宾。是的。你做到了。你请到了多棒的嘉宾啊。
Oh, you did it. You've done good. It's like one of our great, great actors. Oh. I was just like, when I heard that Bradley was going to have her in the film, I just like, it made me, you know what people put certain actors in certain projects? It just elevates. Elevates.
哦，你做到了。你干得真漂亮。她就像是我们最伟大、最伟大的演员之一。哦。我当时就想，当我听说布莱德利要让她参演这部电影时，我只是觉得，这让我觉得，你知道人们把某些演员放在某些项目中时吗？这提升了格调。提升格调。
Elevates. Yeah. And it makes it, it says to the audience, okay, this is what the film is and this is what film isn't. It's real, right? It just kind of gives it this wash, this patina of like, oh, we're in good hands here. She, that, when it gets pissed. Well, well, you gotta,
提升格调。是的。这让它，它向观众传达，好吧，这就是这部电影的定位，而这不是什么。这很真实，对吧？它只是给它披上了一层外衣，一种光环，就像，哦，我们这次稳了。她，那个，当她生气时……好吧，好吧，你得……
a movie that you're gonna be doing with Bradley, when you were telling me about going through some casting and it really doesn't make it. Yeah, it's exciting, it's exciting. And she carries one of those people who does, like you say, kind of raises it and then over delivers. I should have say over delivers, because it sounds negative, but she's so. She comes to my house and delivers stuff.
你将要和布莱德利一起拍的一部电影，当你跟我说起经历选角过程却最终没能参演时……是的，这很令人兴奋，很令人兴奋。而且凯瑞就是那种人，正如你所说，她提升了作品的水平，然后超额交付。我应该说超额交付，因为听起来像负面的，但她太……她来到我家，送了很多东西。
She always brings extra stuff. She brings too much. She overdresses. Yeah, it's like super. How about the Chee and Marcus met. They were pin pals. Yeah, that's wild. Like they met by Cam.
她总是带额外的东西。她带得太多了。她穿得太隆重了。是的，简直超级……切和马库斯相遇的事怎么样。他们是笔友。是的，这太疯狂了。他们是在夏令营认识的。
Friends and camp. They were friends and camp. Pin pals. I mean, that pals. Yeah, that's wild. And like, they met for a camp. They were friends in camp, pin pals. I mean, that's, yeah. I wrote a couple good jokes. These were, he's working on a lot. Go ahead, no, Sean's got a couple good ones from the other day, please.
夏令营的朋友。他们在夏令营认识的。笔友。我是说，那些朋友。是的，这太疯狂了。他们是在夏令营认识的。夏令营的朋友，笔友。我是说，真是……是的。我写了几个不错的笑话。这些是，他正在准备很多。说吧，不，肖恩前几天讲了几个不错的笑话，请吧。
Hey, do you know what happened to the cow that was lifted into the air by a tornado? No. It was an utter disaster. Sean, what was the one? I have a belt. Oh, Jay, I have a belt. Will you killed me the other day about the cataracts? Oh, my God.
嘿，你知道一头被龙卷风卷到天上的牛怎么了吗？不知道。那是一场“牛”转乾坤的灾难。（译者注：原文利用了 utter 和 udder 的双关，中文做本土化处理）肖恩，还有一个是什么？我有一条皮带。哦，杰伊，我有一条皮带。你前几天关于白内障的笑话把我逗死了。哦，天哪。
I said, it's not my joke. I heard that somewhere. Well, you can't say it here, but it's a funny one. Sean, my other one was I have a belt, I have a belt made out of a hundred dollar bills. It's a waste of money. I heard a couple of little chuckles. Boy, if you could do one right now, the third one, and that there's a buy in it, that would be really impressive. Okay. All right. So what did the dad Buffalo say to the kid Buffalo on his first day of school? I don't know. Bye, son!
我说，这不是我的笑话。我是从哪听来的。好吧，你不能在这里说，但这个挺好笑的。肖恩，我的另一个笑话是我有一条皮带，我有一条用一百美元钞票做的皮带。那真是浪费钱。我听到几声轻笑。天哪，如果你现在能再讲一个，第三个，而且里面有买点（buy），那真的会让人印象深刻。好吧。好吧。那么，公水牛在开学第一天对小水牛说了什么？不知道。再见，儿子！
Bye! Bye! Bye! That's pretty great. And smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
再见！再见！再见！这太棒了。而且很聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Bloss. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barberco. If you like Smartless, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen to add free on Amazon music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com-slave-survey. Hi, it's me, the Grand Poova of Bahambad, the OG Green Grump, the Grinch. From Wandery! Tis the Grinch Holiday talk show is a pathetic attempt by the people of O'Vill to use my situation
Smartless由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔姆杰夫和本·巴伯科100%有机且手工打造。如果你喜欢Smartless，现在就可以通过Wondery App或Apple Podcasts加入Wondery Plus，抢先收听且无广告。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上无广告收听。在你离开之前，请在Wondery.com-slave-survey填写简短问卷，告诉我们关于你的信息。嗨，是我，巴汉巴德的大酋长，原生态绿色大坏蛋，格林奇。来自Wondery！《格林奇假日脱口秀》是小镇居民企图利用我的处境
as a teachable moment. So join me, the Grinch, along with Cindy Luhu. Hello everyone. And of course my dog Max. Every week for this complete waste of time. Listen as I launch a campaign against Christmas cheer, grilling celebrity guests, like chestnuts on an open fire.
作为教育素材的可悲尝试。所以快来加入我，格林奇，还有辛迪·露·胡。大家好。当然还有我的狗麦克斯。每周收看这个彻底浪费时间的节目。听我发起一场反对圣诞快乐的运动，像在明火上烤栗子一样拷问名流嘉宾。
They'll try to get my heart to grow a few sizes, but it's not gonna work, honey. Your family will love the show. As you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show on the Wondery app, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show early
他们会试图让我的心长出几寸，但这不管用，亲爱的。你的家人一定会喜欢这个节目。如你所知，我可是出了名的擅长带孩子。在Wondery App或你获取播客的任何地方关注《格林奇假日脱口秀》。你可以通过Wondery App或任何获取播客的地方抢先收听
and add free right now by joining Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Tins the Grinch Holiday talk show early and add free right now by joining Wondery Plus. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《格林奇假日脱口秀》无广告版，只需加入Wondery Plus即可。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 这个单集还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。